This is Jocko podcast number 89 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
Okay.
I was sitting in my tactical operations center in Ramadi
alone.
I was staring at a document
on my computer
and I had to keep wiping tears from my face as I read it.
Yeah.
The document had been submitted to me by the Delta platoon commander.
There was an award recommendation
for Michael Monster
when the award was the metal of honor
for Mikey.
He'd been sitting on an outcropping of a roof in south Ramadi on an Overwatch,
and a grenade,
which had been thrown from an unseen location,
actually hit him in the chest and fell to the ground in front of him.
And he could've jumped away from the grenade and he could have saved himself.
Yeah.
But if he had done that,
his teammates,
okay.
That we're positioned next to him,
they would have been exposed to that blast.
So instead of moving away from the grenade,
Mikey jumped on the grenade.
You smothered it
and he absorbed it's lethal explosion.
Yeah.
Thereby saving our teammates
and at the same time sacrificing his own life.
The morning that it happened,
September 29th,
2006 I got a call from the battalion commander from the first of the five oh six
an outstanding officer and leader that I respected and admired
and this element from Delta platoon had been in the field receiving fire and
returning fire motion the morning,
which was nothing new or nothing unusual,
but it had escalated
and I knew that there had been trouble.
And when the colonel called me,
he told me that there had been a,
a bad fight.
And then he went down the list of my men describing quickly what their wounds
were and what their status was and,
and pretty much telling me that they were going to be okay
until he got to Mikey
and I could hear a shift in his voice.
You became very grave and very serious and that could hear the,
this sympathy in it.
And I knew what was coming.
Mikey got hit bad.
You got hit really bad Jocko.
Yeah,
right.
I don't think he's gonna make it
in my heart.
Jumped through my chest and then it sank
back down to my stomach and then erupted into my brain in a maddening rush of
anger and horror and gut wrenching sadness.
And I grabbed all that insanity and all that emotion and I pulled it back into
my mind and I held it down there while I uttered the only words that I could
muster,
Roger that sir.
And when the Delta platoon commander,
who's one of my best friends and a very close friend of Mikey's,
when he called me,
we were mechanical.
We had work to do.
He debriefed me,
I listened,
we discussed the followup and the next steps and the resupply in the operational
impact of the casualties.
We held it together.
And the next day I talked to one of the seal officers that Mikey had saved.
I talked to him on the phone because he was in Germany already with the other
seal that had been wounded badly on the rooftop,
both of whom would have been dead if it hadn't been from Mikey.
They were only wounded.
And because of that,
they weren't heading home.
And when I talk to
this young officer,
he explained to me what happened with perfect clarity.
Mike,
he could've jumped away and saved himself,
but he did not.
He's only movement was toward the grenade.
Mikey did not hesitate
what kind of a man
does that,
but when I was a brand new guy at seal team one,
I began to learn and understand what kind of man did that
you see as a young enlisted seal at seal team one.
There were two pictures on the quarter deck
just to
the pictures were of seal team ones,
medal of honor recipients,
Lieutenant Bob Kerrey
and petty officer.
Second Class Mike Fortner
and we young guys,
we memorize their names as well as the name of the seal team.
Two Medal of honor recipient,
Lieutenant Tom Norris,
and we read their citations over and over again and debrief them amongst
ourselves.
But we young enlisted seals
we focused on on Mike Thornton.
He was an enlisted man
like we were
and we had heard about him
then he was a legend,
not only for his actions but for his reputation as a seal,
as an operator,
as a leader,
as an all around bad ass frog man that we all aspired to be
as a young enlisted seal.
He was the mark.
He was the example.
He was Mike Thornton
and a few months after checking into seal team one,
I was in Virginia Beach.
I was going to a school at the navy base there on little creek and one day after
work we to a place called Papas pub.
Now mind you,
I wasn't even old enough to get in,
but the,
the chief snuck me in there and as we were sitting there having some food and
talking,
a handful of other seals walked in and they were wearing their full dress choker
whites
and one of them was a big monster of a man and he had a rack or ribbons up to
his shoulder and the metal of honor around his neck.
And I knew exactly who it was.
It was Mike Gordon
right there in front of me,
the ultimate seal,
the ultimate hero standing there in the flesh.
They're my chief looked and he,
he saw how Austrac I was and he told me to go over there and say hi,
which I did.
Now again,
I was a new guy and you'd have my trident yet and at seal team one at the time
as I have accounted over and over again,
we knew guys pretty much got treated like worthless scum.
But when I introduced myself to Mike Thornton,
slap me on the back and said welcome to the teams.
And then he told me I'm from team one too.
I'm from team one too.
And then he bought me beer and treating me like I was his brother,
the man himself treating a pathetic new guy like me.
Like why wasn't one of his long lost buddies
and I never forgot that attitude and that humility
and I would see Mike fort and occasionally over the years and I and I square,
it always seemed like he remembered me,
at least in my mind.
But years later,
he actually did get to know me a little bit when Mikey monsters parents received
the medal of honor from President Bush in the White House.
I was
with Mike Thornton again.
Okay.
And after that solemn ceremony,
well,
we went and we drank and we raised hell and we raised our classes to Mikey into
the rest of our fallen brothers and Mike Fort and treated me and the rest of our
task unit
the same way he treated me when I first met him,
like we were all brothers.
And that night
now that I had seen combat myself and seen with my own eyes,
the bravery and the selflessness and the sacrifice that is the very core of our
community.
I finally understood why Mike Thornton treated us all like brothers.
It's because we were
and we are
okay.
And with that it is on absolute honor to have here tonight
I hero legend,
a Patriot
and someone I'm so proud to be able to call brother retired seal and medal of
honor recipient,
Mike Thornton.
Sir,
welcome aboard.
Thanks shark goes.
Thanks.
So,
and it's my honor to be here too.
Um,
you are unbelievable warrior as Mikey months or I tell Ya,
my love goes up to George and Sally and then everybody there.
But,
uh,
that was an unbelievable day to have taught me and me there and call on.
And then Todd stuff and uh,
all the other team mates there,
it was a lot different than when I received my medal.
So,
uh,
but it,
it was an honor that these young men are getting their respect that they deserve
so much.
And then to bring the whole team on when I received my metal was only Tommy and
Tommy received his mail is only me.
So God bless 'em the navy,
they're finally getting it right.
And um,
honoring these great young men like my [inaudible] sore and ed buyers.
Uh,
so you recently had a book come out,
which is awesome,
and you wrote it with your fellow teammate and,
and fellow metal of honor winner,
Tom Norris,
and also with another seal Dick Couch.
And,
and the book is called by honor bound.
And you know,
for me,
you know,
I was talking about this before the podcast,
before we started recording you,
even though you want to know the,
get to these really good debriefs in the seal teams and you'd think that there
was a uh,
a fault with all these great debriefs and that explained to you everything that
happened on certain missions,
especially highly important missions,
you'd think that that existed,
but it actually doesn't exist.
And for me this book was like the,
the detailed debrief that I always wanted to have.
You know,
not only of the operation that you did with Tommy,
but also
the one that Tommy conducted by himself and,
and both of them are just so well detailed in here and it's just a phenomenal
book to get that kind of granular detail of what you live through.
That,
like I said,
even being in the seal teams myself for 20 years,
I never had as good of an understanding at all as I have with these operations
now.
So thank you for writing it and you don't want to dive into it a little bit
because that's kind of what I do on this podcast is dead,
these books.
And so it's,
you know,
I had to jump around a little bit,
but just talking about your background and where you came from growing up in,
in South Carolina.
Yeah,
correct.
I was born and raised in the hills of South Carolina and my,
uh,
my father was my hero of all times.
You only had a sixth grade education and my dad was in the Philippines from 39.
And you've got lift in the Philippines after MacArthur pulled out.
And,
uh,
he was one of the Raiders over there.
Uh,
they did a movie and,
uh,
I see you only had a sixth grade education,
but he was a guy that everybody respected.
He had his own company.
And,
um,
I used to ask guys what,
he had been worked for my father for 30 years.
You know,
you said it because he and my dad always told me this and that's what I tried to
do when I was in the team.
Should take care of your people,
your people will take care of you.
And My mother gave us love and religion and,
and uh,
but daddy was hard as rocks and uh,
but uh,
you had the greatest respect for that man and everybody else that knew my father
had the same respect for them.
Now you mentioned that your dad had a six get education.
Obviously he was,
he was a hero to you in a successful guy and was able to put things together in
his life and well,
did he ever talk about what he did in the pie?
Not until I had been wounded several times and during my second tour overseas.
And uh,
he said,
I think you'll understand this.
And I said,
Daddy,
I understood the first time I was ever a wounded.
So,
uh,
you know,
wounded in 1939 or wounded in 1969 or wounded and today's war,
I think it brings her a reality.
That war sucks where you look at it.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about that.
I guess your dad wanted you to earn being able to hear good stories from him,
but you got to get wounded before.
I'm going to tell you that fan more than one cause that's a hard man right now.
I'm going to the book a little bit.
This is you talking.
I didn't do that well in school.
I couldn't read and I still have problems with it.
I'm dyslexic.
Back then they didn't call it that.
You are just dumb.
For me it meant that I simply couldn't keep up in school.
I did okay in math,
but that was probably the only thing.
I loved history.
Otherwise I did poorly.
I had to repeat my sophomore in high school and
that really hurt my pride,
so it's no wonder I got in with the wrong crowd and started getting into
trouble.
Nothing serious,
but we were mischievous southern country boys drinking beer and making bad
decisions.
The sheriff was out to the House a few times and there were was a time or two in
juvenile court and I caught a lot of classes.
I had 72 absences in my senior year in high school.
That's a,
that's a pretty,
pretty,
pretty legit record oil.
You could only miss 30.
You automatically.
We failed,
but I didn't think they would want them to see me coming back.
So,
uh,
you know,
to that,
the slug Shia and thank God,
uh,
we found out what he really is and uh,
actually I've never even read the book.
My wife shred it to me five times and I'd make the changes and stuff like that.
But I do have it on tape and if I hear something,
I understand it,
but what I'm trying to say in that is like young men,
no.
Uh,
you may have it tough,
but you can redo this fall.
I've been a successful businessman.
I went all the way through the ranks and I got a commission and I did this and
I'm just trying to say there's only one.
And that's what I tell these kids when they're going through training and
looked,
you know,
that I was only with one person at school.
Stop you and not sure.
So there was always to get across that obstacle,
under it,
around it.
I'll top of it one way or the other.
So don't let something stop you and,
uh,
and for you to move forward and make a better life for yourself in your family.
Awesome,
awesome words right there.
Now,
speaking of moving forward,
it is,
you had like the classic case.
If the judge telling you,
all right,
son,
you can either,
uh,
join the navy or we're going to find a,
a place that you're not going to like so much as home.
Well,
I didn't know this for 20 years later.
My father
told me,
him and the juvenile judge was,
uh,
there were friends with each other and he said,
I'll let you make your first major decision.
You go to juvenile hall,
uh,
basically six months in juvenile hall,
or I could turn around and make their first major decision in my life.
And I had saw that crazy movie,
the five Solomon Brothers during World War II.
Then I saw the movie,
the Navy Frogman with Richard Work.
Mark and I turned around and I said,
I've always wanted to be a UDT frogman and saluted and,
uh,
guide.
Uh,
the guy that,
uh,
enlisted me was a second class machinist mate and nad his name was Ned Johnson.
And when he retired he was back as an 89.
He was the senior enlisted for recruiting the state of South Carolina.
And he tells everybody he made Mike Thornton who,
which today that's outstanding.
So you come in and did you,
did you just went bootcamp and then straight to buds or you guys didn't have
bugs?
You guys called it trading
replacement underdog on underwater demolition recruit training.
I was supposed to go,
I was trying to go straight from there.
They said,
no,
we,
you have to go to outside.
I like I say my dislike,
she was pretty bad and I had to get a 10 point waiver just to get into the teams
and they must have needed people pretty damn bad because I finally got my waiver
and I was in Hawaii and I,
I came back to core and auto went through training and I was thinking about,
you know,
going through training,
here's a,
here's a quote from you coming through training.
We had some instructors who were not only good teachers,
but they were real characters.
There was Vince,
a live era who is part American Indian and a plank holder at seal team one.
He called us Pale faces and we student on fear of instructor Olivia.
Then there was Dick Allen,
a black seal who was the navy boxing champion.
He wants sparred with Mohammed Ali.
When Ali was asked once who hit him the hardest,
he said it was a chief petty officer in the,
in the u s navy named Dick Allen.
And then there was instructor Terry Moe,
who we called mother and boy,
it seemed as if he was always watching us,
making sure everything we did was that we put out 100% so when I was thinking
about during,
this was like when I went through,
I went through in 1991 and there was clearly,
there were some rules in place,
but also the instructors kind of did what they want it to and then what the
command wasn't watching him.
There's clearly,
there's more rules and oversight.
Now,
I,
I've seen that with my own eyes,
but I can't even imagine what it was like when you were going through them.
The instructors must've just been able to do whatever the hell they wanted to do
to you guys,
to events all over the most sadistic son of a bitch I've ever met in my life.
And I was just with Terry Moore the last two days.
Of course,
this is reunion weekend.
Terry still looks like a,
as he did back then.
And Dick Allen used to hang those from the pull up bar and he'd punch you,
us in the stomach.
But I tell you,
if he didn't keep her hands loose,
I mean if you need to keep your hands loose,
he'd kill you.
And,
uh,
of course,
Dick and Vince and Duke both have passed and,
uh,
but their memories,
and there's a funny thing about life itself,
you know,
and,
uh,
it's not what you've done.
This,
the respect you want to gain from the team mates and Dick and Terry and Vince
all grain gained my respect and my love and they'll all the longest might forums
alive in the stores will continue going on.
So that's what I,
that's all I want from,
uh,
the,
my peers to remember who Mike Thornton is us.
And that's what those guys taught me.
Yeah.
We're those guys.
One of those guys,
Vietnam vets.
Were they Korean War vets?
Both.
A
little bit of everything.
Uh,
Vietnam beds.
Then there was Tommy had right.
Get in there too.
They used to call Tommy and I,
after I got in the teams of salt and pepper guy,
he's great big old black guy and a stronger as one a ox.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
actually Vance was the one of the original seals in 1962.
And,
uh,
he went over to nom of course back then they didn't know what they will do with
the seals during that period of time.
So you get a,
you get done with buds and I'm going to the book here.
There were 22 guys who graduated in my class,
18 from the original hundred and 29.
I remember how lucky and proud I felt as I was given orders to seal team one.
Even back then it was no small thing being a navy seal,
but it's one thing to be a seal and yet another to do the work of the seal.
I thought that was an important little highlight there of like when you get done
with buds,
it's just the beginning really correct.
Just,
just you just cracked open the door.
Uh,
then you got to go through the damn door and then after we get through the door
that you got to prove yourself and like,
like you were saying,
we're nobody back then,
you know,
if you hadn't had a couple of tours of Vietnam,
you were just trash as far as they were concerned.
Yeah.
Uh,
so going to the book,
my first platoon was Charlie platoon.
We were in country from 1969 through from December,
1969 through July,
1970.
We worked out of a place called Dong island and it was a great deployment.
We had solid platoon officers and our platoon patio leading petty officer was
Barry.
He knock one of the finest seal operators at team one.
When I made my first deployment,
he was my see Daddy.
It was the same for all of us on our first combat tour and it was an active
tour.
Seems like every other night we'd be out in most of the time we made contact.
I remember we took down a few province level Vietcong cadray types and one time
we had a good intelligence.
We were able to take down an entire VC grenade factory.
It was great.
So that was your first deployment.
W when you talk about Barry and Barry Knock and actually,
uh,
how Kook Nell talks about as well.
It says us as new guys,
even the veterans we worshiped Barry knock.
He was a great leader and a great teacher.
What was it about him that made him just,
that made you guys remember him and revere him so much?
Like you were talking about me and you're grading an introduction,
which I don't deserve that,
but a very,
was a leader.
He took care of everybody and uh,
he's the guy kind of like,
I looked up to my father,
he was my see daddy and he was always there for all of us and me and La last
night,
Tom boy hin and me and Wayne Hampton and might look Foz and uh,
and how Kirk and DOL,
we're all getting a picture together and then remembering the,
the great guys.
And we were all,
we're talking about barrier course.
Barry.
Phil passed away a few years ago and uh,
he,
he's another guy,
you know,
it's like I say,
he'll always be in all our conversations and um,
was somebody we all looked up to,
you know,
so,
uh,
it's the great leadership.
I mean,
he showed us,
and not just the leadership as a leader,
but the leadership he showed us to try be a better person.
And,
and that deployment,
what were you guys doing?
You guys were doing,
we got a point off of boats where you guys going in helicopters.
You guys went on foot patrols,
a little bit of everything,
a little bit of everything.
Foot patrols,
basically.
Sam Pans a whalers.
By that time we finally got the Lss cs,
which were in the late.
And then the medium support sales support craft.
Of course we had the mighty Mo,
a lot of our stuff.
What was the mighty mouth?
Oh,
it was,
uh,
Mike Big Mike Aa and then had the,
a Uc,
it had all the,
the rebarb about 20 inches out.
So if he got hit by an RPG,
explode there and instead of going through the whole,
uh,
we did a lot of,
like I was working down that done,
see float with Steve Fris with the KCS has cause back then we didn't have that
many sales,
so we would help each other.
We knew if they say we need help,
we converse are people right around.
And the uh,
Tom would send,
uh,
the guys that he felt should be going.
So we'd like rich Salono and myself and a bunch of other guys would go out and
help other platoons and stuff.
And where you a 60 gunner?
I was a 60 out of stone or 60,
and I and I carried a car 15 but always carried a Swedish k with me all the
time.
And a pistol is that a backup,
backup,
backup.
So,
uh,
you know,
we have funny things,
and,
and you learn from each other.
So it's like that,
um,
that uh,
uh,
when we hit that a grenade factory,
Mikey sands jumped out and he had a 16.
He didn't lock down,
he didn't lock down is a hitch and is,
is he jumped out of the boat,
is barrel,
fell out in the water and the river and he's down there digging and he's
yelling,
give me one of your guns.
And I said,
hell no,
I'm keeping all my guns.
Cause so,
uh,
you know,
we all learn.
And Mike was a great [inaudible] guy.
He saved our ass as many times.
Uh,
but,
um,
everybody did their,
did their job is just a,
as you were saying while ago,
it was a team effort and my life was saved by people like it might look cause
and other people in my platoon.
And we backed each other up all the time and,
and that was a super active,
um,
actually how,
how Kurkendahl it was talking about you here in the book.
This is how talking,
I can remember more than one firefight where we were shooting and ducking,
sometimes more ducking than shooting,
but Mike would be right there working that 60 with a big grin on his face.
There were plenty of times when I was really scared,
but I'm not sure Mike ever was.
He was reliable and brave,
but I'm not sure he ever knew or understood fear.
Like the rest of us,
he was a great teammate and my God,
he was strong.
None of us could believe how much ammo he carried.
Sometimes he'd go out with a thousand rounds or more that's close to 80 pounds
of just ammo and he'd swim canals with that load.
He'd just shrug and say,
you don't want your 60 gunner to run out of Ammo,
do you?
We got through a pretty active deployment with no one getting killed.
Then a couple of guys stayed behind to break in the new platoon while the rest
of us packed up and left.
They were two of our best and one of them was killed in a Hilo crash with three
other seals.
We took it hard when rich Solano was killed.
But I think Mike took it the hardest.
Mike was a guy who really cared for his teammates.
So even with all that action,
you guys,
when you guys went through the deployment with,
you know,
what did you take?
A few wounded guys,
but he got killed
but nobody was killed.
And actually we were,
I was down at you float and rich Solano was working with the Gulf platoon,
I think.
And then that was when the helicopter and went down.
And,
uh,
of course when you come off a hot Lz,
you're supposed to shut down your aircraft and check the rotor blades because
back then the rotor blades could have a whole,
and it could last for 30 minutes or 45 or an hour.
And,
uh,
the,
the pile of the Hilo wanted to get back for a birthday party or something.
And,
uh,
the Hilo Fountain and actually rich was killed and,
Deralin was killed and Toby Thomas was killed.
Uh,
um,
uh,
who else was there?
Gardner was killed.
So that was one of our biggest,
we lost five guys that do not four,
we lost five.
And I went down and,
uh,
and identified the bodies and,
it was,
you know,
I've only had one bad dream of my whole life and it was after identifying that
cause rich whole face was completely gone.
And the only way I could identify me,
he had a scar on his arm.
And,
uh,
but you know,
a loss of any team mate is,
you know,
as well as I do like Mikey and uh,
and every time,
you know,
every time I lose a,
even a new kid today,
which I've been out speaking to their class and stuff like that,
you lose a little bit more your heart.
I don't know how much more of my heart I got to lose,
but,
uh,
it,
it takes it out of it.
I mean it a,
I don't want to see anybody ever get hurt or especially a loss of a loved one.
And they're all there.
The,
their lives are just as important to me with the new kids today has rich and all
those guys were in port to me back then.
You,
you come home from that deployment and you go into a seal team,
one cadre,
which we actually have talked about on here with Roger Hayden.
Cause we still,
we,
when I was,
uh,
at seal team one and I was in training sale,
we still called it cadray and that was,
I don't know,
20 something years later.
And I never even made the connection.
And,
and Roger and I talked about the fact that,
you know,
some of the training that you guys implemented back there,
the,
the uh,
the point man course where you're walking through and the trip wires are there
and all that.
We still did that.
A lot of the demo we still did.
Um,
and,
and so that's what,
that's what you did when you got home.
You went into that training cell being Kadri and teaching.
And you know,
you mentioned here that you learned a lot being an instructor.
And I always,
I always agree with that.
In fact,
when,
when I was in the seal teams,
no one wanted to go to the training department,
right?
We all want it to just deploy,
just employed,
just deploy.
So when I took over the training,
I always told guys,
look,
if you want to be,
you know,
if you want to master what you do,
you got to go and teach it.
And,
um,
you also mentioned Al Huey in here.
And when I went through buds,
when we were at San Clemente island,
every night when the sun goes down,
we'd sing the song.
Good night owl,
Huey,
good night out.
good night owl,
Huey,
wherever you may be.
And I never knew and still don't know who Al Huey is.
Well I'll you then the camp has called out here.
It's called camp out.
Huey out there.
And,
and honestly,
I make my kids sing this song.
We don't have sun goes down.
Uh,
my,
me and my kids,
we,
we sing this song.
Well,
I'm sure you've heard of the day shy,
a commodore Shively and uh,
Al and uh,
and Dave were best of friends and Al was a,
another mentor like Barry,
not to me.
And uh,
they went through class two of Udt back in the fifties and there were all in
Korea and stuff.
And uh,
he led by example again,
you know,
but I mean,
it's kind of like a,
when he talks better be like,
ef Hutton better be listening,
keeping your ears wide open.
And just as I'm out told me one day,
he says,
you know,
good Lord gave you one mile,
two ears and two eyes.
So you use 80% of that and the other one is shut for a 20% it would be all
right.
And then you,
you
from cadre,
you had a chance,
you went back and deployed again.
But you went to Thailand and teaching the Thai seals.
We took the train,
the tie sales.
I was along with,
uh,
Dick Flanagan and one of the finest officers as Tom boy hand was great officers,
great leader and hours with us on that.
And that's the reason why Alan are,
we're so close.
And we trained the,
uh,
Udt into seal team tactics and then they went up in the work off the borders.
So that's all I can say about that.
Yeah.
And,
and understood.
And then you got home from that and now it looked like the war in Vietnam was
kind of winding down and there weren't full seal platoons deploying anymore.
No more.
So petunias
on the,
basically what we're doing over,
uh,
we were sending,
enlisted LDN and advisers and uh,
like a,
a bunch of the guys that over over there with me on that tour was a,
it was at the reunion and uh,
yes,
it's kind of funny to get together and talk with all of them,
you know,
and talk about,
uh,
but we've lost a lot of those guys which have passed in through age or cancer or
something.
And you know,
it's one great thing about the reunion,
you know,
none of us are getting any damn younger,
so you better get out and sees your shipmates anytime you get a chance.
So,
Eh,
um,
the LDN n you mentioned and just to everyone knows what that,
that those are like Vietnamese,
South Phoenix,
he seals,
seals and the LD nuisance for Louie and die is what it actually in Vietnamese.
I mean like a warrior from the sea or something like that.
Yep,
Yep.
Uh,
so you get a chance to go back again.
And this is funny because typical seal,
you know,
it's like,
oh,
we need you to go back on deployment again.
Yes,
I'll go send me.
Uh,
I'm going back to the book.
So when I got to Vietnam this time,
I spent close to a week at Nha Trang working with the LD and ends.
They're getting a feel for the,
what they were doing in the field.
I'd work with the Vietnamese seals on my first tour back in 1969 s and I saw a
few familiar faces.
You have to hand it to those guys.
For them.
There were no combat rotations.
Life was combat 24,
seven year in,
year out.
They fought until they were killed or as it worked out in the end we lost the
war.
So those are the guys you're working with.
And um,
I think it's,
I mean,
you get into the relationship that you formed with these guys,
which was,
you know,
they were all their brothers.
Yup.
There were that.
You took care of them,
they took care of you.
And of course the reason I to fill that time in our still love to do is cause of
Dane and Quan,
which I explained in the book.
They were,
I'd worked with him on previous chores and many operations and uh,
there were there,
there's just like one of us.
I mean they took care of me.
So that's the reason I handpicked those two guys.
Yang and Quan.
Those were those guys that you had worked with before.
Yeah.
Uh,
Vietnamese seals and so you get to a two.
We non,
am I saying that right?
29 asks for on.
Okay.
So you get to,
to lean on,
this is where you're going to be working out of,
and again,
you're not in a seal platoon.
This is a totally different situation.
And what you had there in to lean on,
if I gathered it all correctly,
he had five enlisted seals from seal team one and then you had to seal team two
officers and in plus with those to seal team two officers who were,
it sounded like they were more junior guys.
Maybe it was our first deployment,
but then Tommy Norris showed up as well as,
oh,
I
see.
Yeah.
Uh,
Shively captain shot,
Commodore Shot.
We had all the seals.
UDT,
ELD
divers,
everybody.
And then Tommy Nelson was our lieutenant commander in an o three,
and he was the head of all the sills.
Tommy was the senior seal operator and country.
Then we had Ryan Combi and a another lieutenant.
It was there.
Then there were all,
they were all east coast guys.
We had
actually,
I think we had,
um,
more like,
okay,
18 enlisted guy.
And then we,
and we broke it up.
Uh,
uh,
and,
Gary,
Gary Chamberlain and Harry Connick Cola went with a lieutenant youth down one
thing.
Then Ryan McCarthy was our boss and I stayed up.
So,
uh,
everybody had had many tours that went down south and I had the most tours and I
stayed up north,
uh,
with a Ryan McCombie.
Then Tommy would go back and forth,
uh,
to run the operations.
Of course it was hard to get a aos approved because,
uh,
you know,
it was pretty,
at that time we were fighting.
And Quan tree and waste city and all that stuff.
And they were trying to overtake it,
but we're still,
we're able to get our opposite.
And um,
you had what,
two squads of LDN and what made up a squad of LDN?
Uh,
approximately I think we had a,
we had more LDNs and we did,
but we separated those guys too.
Uh,
I know when we went on the operation,
uh,
woody was,
we always had a seal as you know,
on an insertion extraction craft.
And Woody had,
uh,
we only had three El Nino was on the with us,
but he had another six or eight on,
on the boat,
the boat,
if we knew this recent blog or something.
So,
and,
and I got to mention this because again,
it's half the book of by honor bound is we've been throwing Tommy Norris,
his name around here.
And when he showed up to work with you guys,
he had been in country for some period of time and he had done this,
this multiple pilot rescue operations,
the bat 21 mission.
And Tommy was,
uh,
will say that I knew about his reputation and he knew about my reputation.
And,
uh,
it was kinda funny.
Tommy and I only operated one time and that was an operation,
but we were of course,
still best of friends.
And,
uh,
I know when,
we,
uh,
resubmitted,
Tommy was putting in for a muddle and it was resubmitted.
Uh,
and then he was upgraded to the medal of honor later on and a greatest friend in
any man could ever ask for.
And,
uh,
I look back on the officers at the leadership we had on,
like I was saying,
Tom boy hen and captain Shively and,
and Tommy and,
and,
uh,
Ryan McCombie and,
and then norm Carly.
And,
um,
you know,
even when we were in six with Marcinko and stuff like that,
it was,
um,
uh,
we had some great leaders,
you know,
and all those guys took care of their people.
That's what I really looked up to them for,
for always being there for the troops.
You know,
they may chew your ass out,
but nobody else is going to.
Now,
once Tommy shows up,
they,
uh,
you get the,
started getting the mission tasking for this mission and that becomes,
you know,
the mission and the Paris peace talks were going on.
But you know,
Tom,
Tom was saying that there's no at the operational level that you guys are like,
oh,
that's great,
but it's not changing anything for us on the ground.
Meanwhile,
they're,
you know,
they're attacking way city and,
uh,
it's just hard.
And so Tom goes down,
he gets called down by,
uh,
by the commodore Schively Schively too,
to get a mission tasking.
And this is,
this is,
uh,
Tom Norris talking.
Uncle Dave had me take a seat in his office.
That's what,
that's what you guys called the commodore.
I never called any of my commodore as an uncle,
at least not to their faces.
Uh,
uncle Dave had me take a seat in his office and I could tell he had something on
his mind.
Tom,
he said the Vietnamese commander of the LDN wants to run a seal reconnaissance
mission to the mouth of the fallen tree.
Quan Viet River.
Is that right?
Quan tree.
Quan Tree River specifically,
he and his superiors want to know about the defenses and enemy disposition
around Quan tree naval base and he wants a Vietnamese LDN n officer to head up
the reconnaissance team.
I want you to run the operation to ensure the mission gets done properly.
But this needs to be seen as a Vietnamese operation.
So that was the task.
Do it.
Doing a reconnaissance.
Correct.
Pretty normal operation.
I'm,
it's pretty standard.
It sounds like you guys were running those type of operations fairly regularly.
Basically.
The NVA had already moved across the quad via at river.
So that was a new,
we knew that and we knew and they were trying to take over Quan tree again and
uh,
and they attacked on waste city.
That was in April and this was an October when this thing was going down.
So we knew it was hot and heavy up there.
But,
uh,
Tommy said yes.
You know,
you never said no to uncle Dave
and,
and so you guys decided or,
or,
or Tom,
you know,
lets you know,
hey,
let's do a small,
a small group.
You're going to take five guys,
correct.
To Americans and three Vietnamese seals,
right?
Obviously the two are you and Tom Norris and then the three,
the three guys that you're going to take with you,
the three Vietnamese that you're going to take with you,
a w two of them were your hand selected guys.
Right.
And then there is another officer,
the other guy was an officer,
right,
right.
Correct.
And he was lieutenant,
I've heard you tell the story in here.
Uh,
he's called Lieutenant Twan.
Yeah,
we,
you always call him ty.
Well,
yeah,
but we put a different name in their book calls.
He kind of made the operation go south.
Got It.
Uh,
so here's the basic concept of operations.
Low.
Really,
the funny part of it,
Tommy said,
I'll do the mission if you let me choose who I wanted to take back then we had a
rotation basically where everybody,
you get a chance to go on the field and with always went in the field with the
new guys and stuff.
And,
and uh,
he said,
I'd like to make a choice.
And Uncle Dave said,
well bitch,
I know who it is.
And he said,
Oh,
we've never operated together.
And he said,
I bet just Mike Thornton.
And you said,
uh,
yes sir.
That's who I want to take with me on an operation.
And actually woody was supposed to be going in on that operation.
And uh,
but we took,
what do you own?
The,
uh,
you know,
search and extraction,
uh,
a means of transportation.
And that's,
that's,
that's bill Woodruff.
Woodruff,
who you talking about.
Yeah.
And we'll,
we'll get into what his role was.
Um,
here's the,
here's the overview of the mission.
And this is,
this is Tom Norris talking to is not a particularly difficult mission and it was
certainly something we'd done before.
So we knew the drill in general.
It was about a 50 mile transit from Toohey non up there.
Could we vet river in our boats with a max speed of about eight knots?
That was a little more than six hours.
So you're talking about a six hour transit.
The plan was to get well out to sea so no one on the beach could know which
direction we were heading north or south.
Once we turned in this case north,
we'd make our way up the coast,
then turn West back into shore.
Then we hope to be on station off the southern bank of the coup Yvette River as
soon as possible after dark.
We then leave the junks and paddle in close to shore and rubber boats and then
swim the last swim ashore from the rubber boats.
We'd insert,
do our job and get out before first light.
We didn't have to be back at two he non before first light,
but we sure as heck want to be back across the beach and away from the coast.
Before sunup.
I was told I'd have offshore navy support in the way of two destroyers.
So if we're running a little late in getting out of there,
I'd have some friendly on call,
fire support.
So that's a real standard mission that,
you know,
when I first got the team one,
we did that,
not,
not the exact same thing and not real,
but we trained it all the time.
You're going to get on,
you know,
mark fives and you're going to have your Zodiacs on there.
Then you're going to get a little closer to the beach in which you get close to
the beats,
you drop off the Zodiacs,
then you get,
get a little bit close to the beach,
and then the last thing you do is get out the boats to women.
You go to your operation.
So kind of standard stuff and you know,
he says it's not something you hadn't done before.
Correct.
Um,
here's what you were talking about with when you're talking about the LDN ends,
going back to the book,
the Ldn ens came in all varieties of experience and capability and courage on
this operation.
We had three very good ones.
Lieutenant Quan was a first rate LDN and officer and Dang and Quan this other
quantities and enlisted to Ella Ldn,
no relation where two guys I'd worked with on my first tour and was with them
again in two e Non Dang and Quan,
we're good to go.
But the problem was quality officer
Quan was hurt.
And that's the reason.
Yeah.
The problem was that Lieutenant,
Lieutenant Quan,
he liked to get after a little bit,
sometimes oil,
those Tulloch all of us.
So yeah,
maybe had too much to drink the night before.
And so what do you get now?
Some kind of accident or what happened?
It was Rodney in a whaler ran into the pier.
He hit his head and they busted both his eyes and he could,
he see he's,
they're both completely shut.
So,
uh,
this is how we got the other do officer,
which I have never worked with.
But uh,
but I had worked many tours.
I mean,
not many tours,
but many operations would.
The other two guys and I'd worked with Quan and he was really good,
but of course he was unable to make the obs so they,
uh,
we brought in another younger officer,
which I'd never operated with.
And this other,
just so everyone knows we're going through this.
The other officer that you now brought on that you hadn't worked with before,
his name was lieutenant won.
Is that,
am I saying that right?
No,
but I'm not going to give you the real name.
Got The Vietnamese speaker and here tighten me up.
Uh,
so you had the,
the navy was out to see the two things that navy was supposed to help you with
was helping you guys do navigation because in this time,
no gps,
it's so easy now I'm embarrassed by how you see this and obviously fire support
if you need it.
Yep.
Basically what they're supposed to do,
his Vectra of saying,
and that's where each ship takes her radar plonge and they shoot it in and they
see where we are in the junks,
uh,
which are,
39 foot concrete chunks is what the,
uh,
and uh,
then they would see where we were then they'd shoot us an asthma and then we
would take our compas and we'd go in there.
Uh,
one of the ships shooting is there were trying to overtake Quan tree again and
he left and went down south to help give gunfire support,
uh,
to,
to help the Vietnamese army and Marine Corps to hold off the Nva.
And,
uh,
when that,
the one guy shot the asthma and he was about three degrees off,
but when you're 15 miles off the beach,
three degrees is a lot.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
everybody said,
the CEO said that's the river rock.
It actually,
it the Ben Hai River,
which was actually in north Vietnam.
So when we went and inserted we're way north of the coffee yet.
Now you had talked about,
uh,
Bill Woodriff,
woody,
you're referring to them as at an important point here.
And this is something we always try to hold true to.
Uh,
you won't always put like a seal with your assets if you can manage it.
So you got to seal out there on the boats that are going to be recovering you
because it's a guy that,
you know,
it's a guy that you trust and you know,
he's not gonna leave you hanging in the room who saying and this,
right?
And,
uh,
you know,
that's a good lesson learned for anybody doing operations right now.
I don't care what unit you're with,
if you're in the marine corps and you're using the army acid,
try and put a liaison officer with the army.
If you're in the army and you're using a marine corps acid,
try and put a liaison officer.
Same thing with special operations because those are the guys that speak your
language.
They're going to be able to predict what you're going to do if things are going
sideways.
It's just a,
it's just a smart move to do.
Um,
and then,
you know,
you talked about how these things started going wrong and you're,
you're off the coast and instead of being,
uh,
where you thought you were,
you're at the Ben Hai River,
which is basically right
south of the bend high.
So we,
and Tommy and I had discussed it and,
uh,
he said,
well,
go ahead and go in.
We'll do what we call a horseshoe ought,
will go in so many clicks and go north and then go back to the Spec to the ocean
and,
and try to,
if we can pick up,
uh,
you know,
if we could do it,
we were doing a body snatch to,
of course by a body stance.
You get your best intelligence that way.
So,
and we used to do direct action missions to go capture bad guys,
but we didn't call them body snatches.
And I'm kind of wishing we did.
It sounds a lot better than to body snatch.
Maybe I should have named those bodies snatching operations.
I would have found it felt a lot better about it.
Uh,
so,
and,
and tactically you're going in,
it's pretty normal.
Um,
you swimming,
it's pretty normal.
You get on the beach.
And here we go.
Back to the book.
This is you talking.
I was carrying the starlight scope,
a bulky first generation night vision device that allowed you to see relatively
well at night.
It was a size of a loaf of bread and weighed eight pounds.
Tommy told me to scout the beach area to see if I could find any of the features
we were looking for or expecting to find like the mouth of the river.
I went north about 200 yards from our position and the same distance to the
south.
And with the starlight scope I could see a good ways up and down the beach,
no river mouth and nothing looked familiar.
Tommy moved inland,
just a short distance to look the area over with his binoculars.
Neither of us saw anything that indicated we were supposed to be.
So,
and then like you said,
you,
you know,
you're in the wrong space,
but you might as well do an reconnaissance while you're there.
And that's kind of the,
the decision that's made.
Um,
and I was thinking about this too,
so I was,
you guys only have five guys and the,
the idea behind that must've been,
hey,
let's travel light and we can maneuver really quick.
And then I got to this list of what you were carrying.
Here's what Mike was.
Karen Mike Talking.
I was the mule on a recon patrol.
I carried a car,
15 car being and just over 800 rounds of five,
five,
six ammunition along with an assortment of a dozen fragmentation,
cs and smoke grenades.
I also had three La rockets and a starlight scope.
All of us carried a medical kit and inflatable Udt over the head life vest.
I also had our silence to weapon,
a 22 caliber automatic pistol with a suppressor attached to the barrel.
We called it a hush puppy.
So not exactly light for,
for regattas.
It's a movement.
I was thinking you guys would try and stay all slick,
but that's,
that's no joke.
What you are carrying
now as your patrol and you start seeing fires and eventually you see movement,
you see bunkers and,
and Tom,
he says,
I think it's about time.
We get the heck Outta here.
You say Roger,
that sir,
it's about zero 300.
You got about three hours of darkness left and you get into a stream and start
moving towards the beach.
Well,
for three different reasons.
One that could show low cell silhouette.
Uh,
we knew that we were within a battalion of Nva at that period of time.
Then we saw tanks and guns and gun in placement.
So we knew that we were way north of where we were supposed to be.
So,
uh,
by getting in the stream,
the tide ranges 18 feet over there.
So the current was running out,
so we knew it was going out to the ocean.
So we got in there by keeping our low silhouette and there we can move a lot
faster in the water.
And,
uh,
hopefully,
we would bump into any of the enemy out there,
which we're starting to move around at that time in the morning.
So,
um,
now you start hearing something correct
and you know,
you hope the patrol and you see what you see is,
uh,
NVA soldiers,
a bunch of them.
It's like an encampment of NVC,
NVA soldiers.
And they,
and,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
but from what their position and where you had moved to in the stream,
now you're looking at them and,
and as you move to the water,
you're going to be exposed.
Is that,
is that the situation?
Well,
actually there were in a base camp type deal and it was a quick reaction force.
The main forces behind us,
uh,
of course says,
that exposed us kinda cut off our southern route.
So to the north of us,
which we knew were going farther north,
there was that big lagoon is a,
as the map show.
And so we would have,
uh,
to our,
eastern flank,
we had the ocean to the western flank.
We had the,
uh,
the lagoon and then to the south we had the bad guys that we knew of.
And to the north,
we had some sand dunes and uh,
but we could see after you pass this one big bunker,
you could see nothing but flat beach.
So we figured that'd be our best,
uh,
objective to move up there.
And Tommy got on top of this,
we thought it was a big sand dune,
but actually it was a,
as a,
as a bunker built and actually had tunnels down inside of it.
So,
and that's the one that you did a recon and you found that bunker the bunker and
brought Tommy there.
Tommy went up there with the radio on,
which was Dang.
And that gave us,
you know,
of course back then it was the radios for PRC 77.
His line of sight,
which you,
uh,
so yeah.
Yeah.
And he's trying to make coms back to a woody or back to the ship.
Back then she has needed,
the shit was a Newport and using the USS Morgan,
that's what those ships were.
Then we had,
we finally got woody,
but woody was done off the mouth of the quality yet he thought,
you know,
after he got their bearings.
So there are a long ways off from where we were.
So at this point,
Quan,
you guys are,
you guys were in that bunker and Quan comes from and back and he says die way
Norris with a starlight scope.
I see two men coming down the beach.
They're quite a way off,
but they're heading our way.
So then you,
you seem like you come up with a plan right there of what you're going to do.
Yeah.
Which to me,
I'm like thinking,
well I'll let you brief what your plan was,
but you see two bad guys coming down the beach and your idea is cool.
It's time to do our body snatch.
Correct.
And I figured,
uh,
the officer,
which name is mentioned,
he was,
he was a good side.
He's like five,
nine [inaudible] a strong,
I mean that's what it guy,
right?
So this is the other Vietnamese or the Vietnamese officer?
Officer Guy,
yeah.
Yeah.
So I put him down on the beach because the,
uh,
the high water line and these guys were walking up and down the high water line
and the other guy was about a hundred,
150,
a hundred yards ahead of the guy calls.
The other guy was walking up in the sand dunes and I figured we've got to make
sure we not Kim out let the other guys just walking by because he's just
tootling down the low,
uh,
the coastline looking around.
And uh,
so I said,
I sent Quan Down with the hush puppy and not Quan,
but uh,
the officer and I sent him down and I said,
I'm on just guys go walk by us.
But when the other guy,
I'll take him out and then I had Quan there with me and Quan after I knocked him
out cold and when the Quan got him,
he takes him up and,
and a secured him.
Since you guys are the two enemy are walking down the beach had a pretty good
distance apart or you say,
okay,
I'm going to get me and Quan,
we'll go get this guy will capture him and then lieutenant or this Vietnamese
lieutenant you go and get this other guy.
Correct.
And you do,
you said kill him right now.
I said if you could take him,
take him to,
okay,
got it.
But he's right on the shoreline.
So the waves are breaking those making a lot of turbulence and noise and the,
and the other guys up in the sand dunes,
he's at the high water log of walking around looking like that.
So I knew he would be the last one there,
but we had to make sure we took him out for sure.
Right.
And then I told the officer he could go up and take this guy out or eliminate
him or just make sure he didn't go back to the village calls
villages on down the beach.
And,
uh,
he,
he stood up,
you know,
lie day,
Mile Lynn and Vietnamese.
I mean,
stop,
come here,
he's got an AK 47,
uh,
the bad guy does,
he's got a,
you know,
a 22 long hush puppy,
which is about from here across this room.
And,
uh,
you know,
he's out there like that.
And then the guy opened,
fired on him.
He's running back towards Tommy and me and I'm running past him because I know
he's on his way to the village.
And as I say in the book,
you know,
they were,
they didn't have radios like everybody did.
So what sometimes they would weigh,
they would,
uh,
sin,
information and shoot somebody arounds in the sky and somebody to answer back.
But they changed all the time.
But at that period of time,
he only shot off two rounds.
So I hopefully that didn't mean something bad or good.
And,
uh,
we got to the opening of the,
um,
he went across the creek,
the creek bed,
and he was heading straight to the,
uh,
entrance to the village and I dropped down to one knee,
hit two shots,
hit him in the back,
he fell down and next thing,
oh hell,
it was 50 to 75 bad guys are chasing us down.
And um,
and I was heading back to Tommy and uh,
we got back and I went,
I moved out on the point is the book explains Song.
So,
so when you,
when you grab our,
now you're heading back to Tommy and that's in that big sort of bunker doom
then.
Yeah.
And so now all you are co located in the big dump bunker?
Uh,
no,
actually I'm out on the very point.
Okay.
And Tommy was up on top of the market.
Got It.
Dang.
And they had taken our,
the guy we did capture up there and he was up there.
So I move the officer to rear security and told them if he sees anything,
let Tommy go and I put clon over all my eastern
flight,
which is the side of the ocean.
So I was about 50 feet ahead of him,
50 yards ahead of him so I could cover,
I could see everybody coming in.
So I was kind of like the point,
but I kept Quan over to own the ocean side.
If they tried to flank me,
he would knock them off.
Then I could see them low goon over here cause see the lagoon.
And so I could see everything out in front of me.
And now the enemy starts calming for you.
Came forward and you start engaging them,
taking them down.
Yeah.
An engaged them and what I'd do,
I'd come up over here,
I'd roll over and come up somewhere else.
I'd throw a grenade over here,
I'd move back till another grenade.
I'd,
I'd move forward where the grenade hit calls I had by that time.
And uh,
I gave him a frost,
preached tenses.
How many people we had.
They didn't know we had 12 or 15 or lonely,
didn't Tommy numerous shooting from up there.
But Tommy was on the radio trying to get communication
and what Tommy was trying to get communications from,
and just to kind of lay this out a little bit,
that the ships had been told,
hey,
we might need fire support.
Correct.
Well when you and whenever you set up fire support for yourself,
you always set up what we call pre predesignated firing position.
So hey we,
you know,
you name them,
whatever you're going to name them,
a,
B,
c,
d one,
two,
three,
four.
You give them girls names,
whatever car names,
but it's real easy to jump on the radio and say,
Hey,
fire it.
Position Bravo now and the,
you know,
whatever fire support can start hitting that.
That's,
that's great.
If you're where you're supposed to be and then that's the issue.
Okay.
So Tommy starts doing its best and saying,
hey,
fire rounds at this pre designated spot.
Go ahead.
They fire rounds of that pre designated spot.
Guests could even see it.
So they started moving north of that period of time and there was shooting smoke
in the air then.
And uh,
the firefight went for almost,
uh,
almost three hours,
actually two hours and 55 minutes.
And we had eliminated a ball,
a lot of these guys and they started falling back.
And
so there's five of you that are making like 30,
40,
50 guys fall back.
Well,
just four of us calls.
Got It.
The other guy never shot a round
and that's just you're taking good fire discipline.
Correct.
Uh,
one or two rounds of time making good hits and making sure what I'd do,
I'd shoot in the sand about an inch and not see their heads come up.
Then I'd shoot uh,
uh,
about an inch below the sand and I get a head shot every time.
So you could tell that and then you'd roll over,
you know,
then what's the grenades you were knowing that we're getting,
as you mentioned,
what are grenade?
Of course we have a four second delay in hours and their,
their grenades.
We had
pulled those things before and they'd go want to go anywhere from 14 seconds to
second so they don't have good quality control and their grenade factories like
we do.
Uh,
let's see.
Yeah,
you're,
you're talking about that you're sending guys off now.
You're,
you're continued to shoot,
you're continuing to hold your position.
You're,
you're about halfway your ammo at this point.
And then speaking of these grenades,
you're in one of these positions and boom incomes,
one of those grenades to your,
to your spot.
What'd you do about that?
Well,
I yelled grenade and I grabbed it and threw it back.
I was going to 00020003000 about Tom.
I hit 8,000 to jam grenade,
came back over and I'm going twelve thousand thirteen thousand calls of course,
where you thousands and I gives you a good second.
Not threw it back.
And,
and the,
the grenade went back and forth five times and I was at 20 1020 2000.
I said this saying it's got to go off.
And it went off and I was hit six times and my bag was shrapnel and I just
yelled out.
I didn't say nothing else.
And when I yelled out,
I just stayed there and I looked up and there was four guys coming across and I
eliminated all four of those guys.
And that's when we found out they started falling back.
And Tommy said to her,
falling back and I said this,
he said,
are you okay?
I said,
you know,
I'm wounded,
but I'm okay.
We still very,
very mobile.
And uh,
of course the adrenaline's pumping.
Like God knows what.
And uh,
and uh,
uh,
and you don't worry about yourself.
You stood just,
you know,
you need to get out of there.
Assault.
We knew.
Now at this point it seems like they're falling back a little bit.
And it looks like from,
from the way it's described,
there's basically another dune that's a little further back from where you are,
approximately 500 yards.
And that's to the north,
to the north,
going right by itself.
I mean,
everything else is flat except for that one too.
And so what you're,
what you guys hatch the plan real quick.
All right,
let's get to that thing.
It's further away at create some distance and then from there we can eventually
get in a water and get outta here.
And you know,
I talk about cover and move all the time.
And that's like the fundamental principle of how we fight.
And in a normal situation you would just get little terrain features and you'd
move back a little piece at a time because,
uh,
because that's how you support each other.
In this one,
there was no where to hide in between those two.
No.
So you guys made the call of Tommy and who's going to stay up there?
Who's Tommy and dying to radio moon stay up there.
And Tommy said,
you fall back that time
very to Tom.
I was the only one who had any,
it had been wounded.
But what we did,
I looked across at a pair of binoculars.
I looked across and I said,
I can understand why because I counted almost a hundred guys.
And Tommy said,
there's a lot more than that.
And it was a Nva battalion.
They were trying to circle us and uh,
and by the time I got back,
uh,
as the book says,
Dang comes back by himself,
cause Tom,
he had been shot in the head at that period of time.
So,
so you guys,
they put down copper,
they put down cover fire for you,
right?
And then you fall back,
you're doing what you're supposed to do and you got the Vietnamese lieutenant
and you got Quan with you on with it.
You get back to that position and
that means Lieutenant Norris is still up in the big bunker getting ready.
He's waiting for your fire support.
And while that's happening,
I'm going to go to the book,
uh,
right here I was asking for naval gunfire right onto our position.
And he says,
those rounds could have hit Dang and me just as well as the bad guys.
But I had no choice.
The guy on the radio came back and said,
understand fire for effect.
And I said,
absolutely put it on us.
And he said,
are you sure?
And I said,
just get it in here.
And so they actually,
as they were called in this naval gunfire,
Tommy was like seeing guys common and like through the grace of God,
a one big round hit there,
they hit them and got a lot of bad guys.
And then again going back to the book,
I went back to getting the law ready to fire.
That's a law rocket.
I could hear the ship shooting,
but that's the last thing I remember.
And then the narrator comes in and says,
at that point in the fight,
Tom Norris took an AK 47 round to the left side of his forehead.
The bullet entered his skull at the orbital socket of his left eye toward a
section of his skull exposing his brain and caught a shallow furl along the
brain itself.
Dang saw his officer go down and the extent of his head wound,
he's lieutenant had been shot dead knowing there was nothing he could do.
He made for the others who had just taken a position on the next dune to the
north.
As he ran,
he took around through the radio.
He still carried on his back,
knocking him down the round,
destroyed the radio and saved his life.
But fragments carried through into his back.
Dang.
Picked himself up and kept running.
It took him close to 10 minutes to reach Mike.
Where's Tommy?
Mike Ass.
Dang,
when he reached him,
whereas die Wei Dai way is dead.
Dang replied.
And this is it.
So you know your trusted Vietnamese fellow seal says,
Hey,
look,
the lieutenant that's Dai way is the tenant.
He's dead
and this is what you do.
I'm going to the book here.
I told Quan and the others to wait here that I was going back for Tommy.
They tried to stop me saying it was no use.
He was dead.
I believed them.
I too thought he was dead,
but I wasn't going to leave them behind.
We never leave anybody behind.
So no way was I going to be the first to do that.
Had I been wounded or dead,
he'd have come back from me.
That's who we are.
Dang said he was dead and I had no reason not to believe him.
It didn't matter.
And what if by chance he was still alive.
I could not have live with myself if I have left him behind not knowing or what
the Nva might do to him if he were still alive.
That whole area,
south of the bunker was littered with bodies and they would be looking for
revenge.
I had close to a quarter of a mile to cover and the last part of it was uphill,
but I ran all the way.
The initial salvo from the Morton,
that was the ship out at sea,
although I didn't know it at the time that it was the Morton shooting had made
the bad guys think twice about advancing on the Dune with the bunker.
When I got close,
I saw them moving carefully towards the bunker.
From where I could see they were flanking the bunker and moving in from the east
or the beach side as well as from the south.
I saw Tommy lying on the west side of the bunker.
Two guys were climbing over the top as they moved in from the east.
They moved cautiously and got within a few feet of him.
I shot them both and moved to where Tommy was.
He had an unbelievable head wound.
The whole side of his forehead was gone.
His brain was visible.
You could actually see it.
The front lobe of his brain was kind of pushing out through his skull.
I could see why.
Dang said he was dead.
I sure thought he was.
I picked him up,
put him over my shoulder and started running.
I also grabbed his AK 47 as I knew I was getting low on Ammo.
I hadn't taken more than 10 steps from the bunker when there was this explosion
behind me from naval gunfire round the concussion picked us both up in the air,
lifting Tommy off my shoulder and tossed us forward 10 or 15 feet.
I literally saw him move my shoulder,
leave my shoulder and fly through the air.
When I landed,
I sat there for a moment,
stunned trying to orient myself and catch my breath.
Once I sorted myself out,
I crawled over to where Tommy was lying in the sand.
Once I got to Tommy again and started to pick him up,
he spoke to me for the first time.
He said,
Mike Buddy,
and that was when I knew he was alive.
I said,
can you run?
And he says,
I can run,
but I can't see.
But he really couldn't run.
Then he blanked out again.
I put them in a fireman's carry and took off for the Dune to the north where had
left the others.
I heard him talking now and then,
and I guess he was fading in and out,
but I knew he was alive and I put all my energy and focused to covering the
ground between where we were and the other dude
where like I said,
you need it on that you and I've talked about the camaraderie and the respect we
have for each other and even though Tommy's a much smaller than I am a,
he would have done the same thing for me.
I know that so,
so it's like you say,
you,
you know,
if you die,
which were all under,
we understand what our job is as being navy seals,
but I could never live with myself knowing that if he was dead,
I thought he was dead.
But,
uh,
with the grace of God,
he's still with us.
So as I was running back with him,
I got shot through my left calf through my,
uh,
my left calf and I fell to the ground and we got back in there.
Squad and Dane given us cover far.
Were you,
uh,
like when I've done stuff that was maybe not the safest things in the world,
I never was really thinking like,
oh,
this is dangerous.
Were were you thinking,
uh,
oh,
this is really dangerous?
Or will you just,
oh,
he's over there and I got to go get him because that's what we do,
what we do.
So that's what it is.
You don't,
you know,
fears are good thing,
but you got to focus.
I mean,
if,
you know,
I could have sat down her today,
we were all gonna die.
I'm just gonna lie here and,
and do it.
But I said,
I'm going to take as many of those slbs down as I can.
And uh,
you know,
and then the thing is,
is that,
um,
uh,
it,
it was like we should go back to what we are and the Camaraderie and going
through training and why we do things and things like that.
And I think the broader was my father and there's like go back to,
I look about it cause my dad never would have left me behind her,
anybody else behind,
you know,
and that's what she instilled in us as we go through training.
And that's what's instilled us,
you know,
a know a Tom boy hand was saying last night you said,
I don't think he in new one.
Fear was,
well I knew what it was,
but I mean,
being afraid,
you know,
if you worry about being afraid of everything,
you should never be in the field because you're not focused on what,
what you're trying to do.
So that's the whole thing is,
you know,
so we're out there to do a job,
so we'll just get the damn job done yet.
It's interesting to me.
I would,
I think guys would feel more afraid when we were getting ready to go in the
field when even me,
you know,
when you have time to think like,
oh we're going down this street,
which has had,
you know,
17 ids on it in the last four days and there's guaranteed to be another one on
there tonight with a question is,
is it going to hit you or is it going to hit someone else?
And that's,
I would see the look on guys' faces while
we were getting ready to go out and you could see a little bit of that.
But once you're in the field,
everyone's doing what they do.
They're just doing their job.
Just like flicking the switch,
you know,
switch you get,
you'd get your mind and what you're supposed to be doing.
So for guys doesn't have his mind in the game.
He's going to stay at home.
He ain't going out in the field with Mike Thornton though.
Prompt you that.
Now this is one of my,
one of my favorite parts of the book that is,
well,
I'll,
I'll read it when I got this,
is you talking,
when I got back to the Dune Dang and Quan,
we're waiting for me providing cover fire.
Lieutenant Twan was nowhere in sight.
He had already made it for the water to escape.
But God blessed Dang and Quan,
they waited for me and we're still in the fight even though Dang was wounded.
They said,
Mike,
what do we do now?
And I said,
we swim,
which is the classic seal scenario in that the water is our salvation.
We have that special experience in the water and,
and people aren't comfortable in the water and it's our home.
And that,
that was just the classic answer.
These guys were stayed.
Where do we do now?
Remember we were combat swimmer is not going on.
Better runners.
Bug running does help.
So
now,
now talk about when you're getting,
now you're moving to the water you're carrying and Tommy,
what goes on then?
Well,
uh,
I didn't inflate Tommy's life.
Check it as some of the stories said.
I,
I was using Tommy like a surfboard and then every time a wave would break,
I'd push them under the cold water and bring him up the other side because the
worst thing you could do is have a wave.
And we had six sets away.
He's coming in and that's how Quan ended up getting injured.
You guys shot.
And uh,
so after I got Tommy out,
that's when I put,
and I could never find Tommy's life check it.
And he had it in a pocket down on his calf.
And I said,
why?
He said,
well,
I wonder if I get a bullet hole in it.
I said,
it's good because we can put a piece of tape and then,
you know,
if you have a,
sucking chest wound where I can take.
So I took my life,
check it off me,
put it on his head,
and I took the,
you know,
the old Udt,
I took the harness,
but I just put a little bit of air and I started a breast stroking out to sea.
And that's when I saw Quan was in not going anywhere and I could see dangled in
front of me.
And so I swam over and Grab Quan and I put Quan in front of me had been shot
too.
He had been shot in the femur and also his buttocks was completely kinda gone.
He though he couldn't.
So I uh,
so you're wounded,
you,
you got shrapnel in your back,
you got shot in the leg.
Like you got Lieutenant Norris who's basically unconscious dying and now you've
got quant who he can't move himself.
He's a mobile as well.
Correct.
And Dang is leading point.
As you guys are paddling out and you're carrying both these other guys
through the water.
So what I did,
I took Quan and put his arms.
I'll put my arms or knees quantum's arms and he yelled Tommy like this.
And I started breast stroking and two we got out past the a ranger there,
weapons.
And at that period of time I inflated Cohen's life check with a little bit.
Then I actually tied his life jacket to my waist and I told Kwan and swim with
Tommy on my back.
Um,
here's again a typical,
I think this exemplifies the seal attitude right here.
This is you talking every time Tommy woke up,
it was Mike,
you got everyone.
I could only count four of us.
Where's the other guy?
I'd say I got them,
I got everyone and then he drift off again.
Then when he woke up.
But again,
it was Mike,
you got everyone.
Do you have all of them?
And I'd say,
damn it Tommy,
I got them all.
Okay,
they're accounted for.
But I just love the fact that,
you know,
you got a guy that's clearly close to death and when he does become conscious,
his number one concern is does he have his guys with
that's true.
And that's the way great leadership is.
Sometimes people surpass that because,
uh,
you know,
but it goes back to the thing that you and I were talking about earlier.
You take care of your people,
your people will take care of you
now.
Um,
you get out,
you know,
pass like you said,
pass the small arms fire and,
and again,
Dang and Quan keep asking Mike,
what do we do?
What do we do?
And each time you said we swim,
we just keep swimming.
We'll swim south all the way to two.
We non if we have to.
That's correct.
And that's what you did.
You start,
you kept swimming and kept swimming and kept swimming and you're out there for
three hours swimming.
And,
and just to put that into some perspective for people that have never swam in
the open ocean before,
the longest swim that you do in seal training is 5.5 now nautical miles,
which is 6.2 statute regular land miles.
And that takes,
depending on the current,
depending on how good your swimmer you are,
that's the longest swim that they actually make you do.
And that takes like three,
four,
sometimes five hours.
That's the longest one that they make.
You do.
And by the way,
they give you a little water break inbetween.
So here you are
swimming this and you,
you're wounded,
shot in the leg.
Like I said,
you're dragging these other guys now.
Luckily,
Bill,
we're drifting.
We talked about this earlier.
You had,
you saved her life.
I mean,
Billy wouldn't give up almost.
He would not give up.
He kept looking for us and the,
and actually the Morgan thought they'd killed us all they thought and they ever
knew until several years ago that we were
the whole hive.
No,
that's,
that's actually a great,
and again,
obviously I can't cover the whole book on the,
on,
on this show,
but get the book because uh,
uh,
there's Dick Couch did a great job of actually going out and talking to the
people that were,
that were firing,
talking to people on the Morgan and you're right,
they,
they fired rounds and all of a sudden they didn't hear anything.
And the fire danger close rounds meeting like,
well rounds that we know are going to be very close to our friendly forces.
And then they never heard another word.
So they're fought was horrible.
We must have hit our own guys.
And,
uh,
but luckily,
and any other thing that's interesting about bill woody Woodruff is the other
lieutenant lieutenant had actually gotten out to them and told them,
hey,
this is what happened for the lieutenant got killed.
Mike went to go get him and never came back.
That's what he got told.
So the word got back to woody and he called the Newport news new went out with
the navy blue that Tommy was dead and I was missing in action and uh,
they were still looking for Quan and dying.
So,
uh,
okay.
So here's actually here we hear here in the book,
and again,
Dick Couch did a great job getting back with all the,
all the guys that had were there,
or at least a lot of them.
And he's,
he's talking to,
to woody here,
Bill Woodruff.
He says it was about 1130 and I saw the Newport news began to move off to the
south.
Then my junk skipper got a call from the other junk that was off to the north
and slightly in shore from us.
We are about a half a mile apart.
So as to better search the area,
they said they had swimmers in the water and we're going to get them.
You can't know what that meant.
So there it is,
uh,
because bill stuck around.
Yeah,
I have the greatest admiration and respect for bill.
Uh,
I'm glad to bill found does kilz bills.
We'll do a counter attack.
And then,
then we had Ryan McCombie done into tune on getting a bunch of guy,
everybody else.
So it was left to come and find us.
So that goes back to the,
uh,
things about taking care of your teammates,
you know,
and,
and thank God they did find this because,
uh,
none of those guys would have made her,
cause I mean they had over 600 bad guys up there.
So,
you know,
sometimes you,
you don't want to leave nobody behind,
but sometimes you gotta take your losses too.
You know,
it was the,
uh,
two things,
and I,
I've heard this from other seals,
from Vietnam to missions.
There's no question we're launching on is down pilot and seals in trouble.
We're going.
Yup.
And that's what those guys that were still in [inaudible] were doing.
They were getting ready to go.
Your welcome.
They were coming after us,
you know,
and uh,
uh,
say it,
but I figured we'd lost everybody you're trying to get in to get us to go like
shit.
It had the gun emplacements they had tank scenario.
We weren't the a heavy duty guys,
but that goes back to even what we have today with,
you know,
like Eric Crichton trying to go in and uh,
losing the guys that,
you know,
we go,
we're going to go in and get our boys back out and uh,
uh,
you know,
and,
and you know,
we passed the baton on back from where I am and these,
these young men who serve us now I have the greatest admiration.
There are a lot smarter than I am cause they,
uh,
I mean again,
he got,
these kids are going through trying to nail,
are all going to college education but they're enlisted guys.
They just want to be in the teams
and the training they do is awesome.
Way better than I had it when I went through there,
there and there have very high standards.
Great guys coming through.
Um,
so you guys now get back on board,
but obviously this didn't go over yet because you got severely wounded three,
especially Tommy Norris and you,
you actually told them bring the Newport news back cause there's a correct,
there's a doctor I knew there was a doctor on board because it was a Navy
cruiser and they had a lieutenant commander on board and I called woody and I
said,
we have four Wia in one critical and uh,
and they Newport news dude turn around and we started steaming and our junk
woody was on the other junk are junk,
got there first and we passed down.
I was,
uh,
boats and chair.
Then we just pass down on rigor than we've put Tommy inside that you've got him
up there.
And uh,
I actually pick Tommy up out of it and carried him down because the thing was
too wide to get through the hack.
So I picked Tommy back up and carried him down and laid him on the Gurney.
And the doctor's office.
And
then I got called to the bridge to debrief the admiral,
what was going on.
This is a,
again,
a great find by Dick Couch,
another,
another seal that,
that wrote the book and other Vietnam Seal.
And he found a guy named dot chuck Zehnder.
And Chuck Zehnder was a corpsman on the USS and Newport news.
And I'm not sure why,
why Dick Couch found him or how that worked,
but did,
he's the guy that he found and he's talking about when you guys came on board.
And what was interesting was that,
uh,
a few months before,
actually a month earlier,
they'd had a turret explosion on the USS Newport news and it killed Loven killed
1111 and wounded 62.
And so they,
these,
the medical staff on that was,
they were kind of primed.
Luckily they were used to,
they had just been through basically a horrible mass casualty drill and they
were somewhat ready for it,
which,
you know,
again,
by the grace of God,
they weren't,
they had some recent experience with dealing with wounded and,
and so that's why they were ready for this.
And that that's according to a chuck Zehnder,
this,
this Korman.
And here's,
here's chuck Zehnder talking.
When they came aboard,
they were pretty scruffy lot.
My job in handling casualties was triage.
I saw them first,
evaluated them and sent them on to a senior medical person,
corpsman or doctor for treatment.
I remember seeing this one American,
I couldn't believe his head wound.
His forehead was simply blown away.
I had two thoughts.
One,
it was a good thing he was in salt water or heat of have bled to death.
My second fault was this man will not be alive in the morning.
He went straight to Dr for Cheerio for Chiro who was waiting for him in surgery.
There was this big guy who was with him and he carried him from the fan tail to
the sick bay.
We had to force him to let go so we could treat him.
He wanted to go into surgery with him.
So that was,
you know,
it was obviously,
and uh,
he also said that,
yeah,
when,
when they came out and said,
hey,
we need to check you out.
And you looked and you said no,
the Tommy comes first.
The rest of us can wait.
MMM.
This is chuck Zander talking again.
While we were treating the Vietnamese seals,
I kept my eye on the big American.
I finally got him to sit down so we could look them over.
I saw blood on his pant leg and I cut into his trouser.
I saw bullet hole in his leg,
my eyes got big and I called another corpsman over to look at it.
I said,
we better treat that.
And the seal said something like,
yeah,
whatever.
Okay.
He just didn't seem to care.
But he did care about the others and kept asking you about them.
Especially his lieutenant.
We knew he was a lieutenant because the other big American seal said he was,
he had no rank insignia on him.
So again,
okay.
Your number one priority is your teammates.
MMM.
Another person.
So Te,
so you guys make it back.
Uh,
the ship gets you back to land.
Tommy eventually gets casualty evacuation to the Philippines.
Yeah.
I uh,
got on the radio and Ryan [inaudible] and uh,
we met her evac Tommy off,
uh,
by helicopter to Denang and Ryan flew down on a helicopter and he was waiting in
Denang and Ryan stayed with Tommy the no,
send a one 41.
Uh,
cause we knew we were,
we had our appeal,
diabetes Admiral Stockdale Bud day,
people like that out.
And uh,
uh,
so all the top doctors,
you know,
neurosurgeons,
all those guys were over there cause they had already pulled everybody out of
Vietnam with the exception of just general practitioners.
And uh,
by the time we got Tommie through the whole operation,
you've got him to the Philippines to Clark's,
it was almost 19 hours long.
Matter of fact,
in his operation lesson,
a 19 and a half hours,
his first operation and they stayed in touch with us.
But I stayed on board of the Newport and news to the following day to take care
of the Vietnamese spoke English.
But I spoke of a pretty,
I mean I,
uh,
I was fluent in Vietnamese and so I stayed on there until we got them all
patched up.
This is the doctor talking major Walter Grand.
He's the neurosurgeon that they had to get this guy get,
get Tommy Norris too in the Philippines.
Correct.
And he says when he arrived,
we took them directly into the,
or at the time general military battlefield protocol held that the patient
needed to be needed to be or should be conscious going into surgery.
And I was surprised that someone with this series of a head wound would be
conscious and conversant.
Fortunately he was,
he was still dressed in his operational gear,
which were blue jeans and a black t shirt of some kind.
As I was conducting my initial examination,
I remember that he was conscious but,
but just barely,
I could tell he'd been through a lot.
Then he seemed to come more alert and ask sir,
can you tell me about my men?
I know we got them all off the beach,
but can you tell me if they're okay?
Yeah,
Julian.
it's um,
it's the teams
now they get done with the surgery that you're talking about.
Incredibly long surgery.
And here's the doctor talking again on removing the bandage and inspecting the
wound.
We talked and I sensed that he didn't know that he no longer had a left eye.
I was reluctant to tell him as he had endured a great deal,
but he was a pretty tough fellow.
So I told him that we were unable to save his left eye.
He thought about it for a second and then said,
do you think they'll kick me out of the Navy because of that?
I said that I couldn't really answer that,
but I took it as a good sign that he still wanted to be a seal.
Then the funny part,
it wasn't the,
as much as it was
the loss of the front Lobel part of his brain that was,
uh,
I actually don't think that's funny.
Sorry.
I don't think it is either.
So when you say that,
what do you,
what do you mean that,
what was the,
uh,
you're saying,
hey,
they're not going to kick you out of,
even though you've lost part party your brain.
Well,
I think that was a,
one of the,
that we talked about it cause he wanted to stay in,
he was,
uh,
already chose to be a lieutenant commander at that period of time.
And uh,
of course she owned medical hold that does that.
She goes to stop and uh,
but Tommy would have been a great,
he would have been a great ad role.
I mean he really would have done us proud as of Ryan McCombie two and,
and a few other guys who didn't go up through the ranks of a to the top.
But we've had some great leadership up there.
And I'm Eric Olsen,
Bill McRaven,
uh,
Joe McGee,
Joe Kernan,
Maguire,
Burke,
Callan.
I mean,
the way you look,
I watched the teams grow from this,
Oh oh four was as high as you could go and still be in the teams.
And now look,
as I look at their thing and the guys are,
I just amaze me every time I looked
can read something or something,
how much I'm so proud of each one of these young men who serve this great nation
of ours.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's amazing.
Again,
that,
that attitude,
it's just constant.
And you know,
I had this with my guys that got wounded that none of them wanted to go home.
They wanted to just stay.
They didn't care if they just had to sit and stay and watch.
They wanted to stay with us in Iraq.
Uh,
well,
you know,
I mean,
how proud all you guys were when we were there with Admiral Olson and you guys
were receiving your awards in the Pentagon,
you know,
after Mike
and,
and you know,
you look at the guys are job and those guys that,
you know,
of course
he lost his life in a very basic operation.
And,
uh,
but you know,
the,
even though when they,
they had the diversity against him,
they continued to strive to make their life better.
Well,
Ryan Job's the classic example.
We don't know.
He was blind in both eyes and he was telling me he wanted to,
he was already back in America and he's on the phone telling me,
can I please come back to Iraq?
I want to be with the platoon.
Yup.
Yeah.
And uh,
it goes in and gets his college education and it has a beautiful family and uh,
he's,
I remember there was a,
I was able to put the purple heart on him down then Tommy and I were there with
the Admiral Olson of course.
Was that it at Bethesda?
Where was that?
Was that in the hospital?
No,
no,
no.
He was at the Pentagon.
Oh,
camera.
Oh wait.
At the award ceremony that we had for you guys to the big ones.
And then we went down and he gave other from team three we gave a call and green
was there more green was,
it was awesome.
It was the task unit bruiser a award ceremony at the Pentagon.
We were all pretty surprised to be there doing that.
But yeah,
Ryan job.
So you guys put the Purple Heart
on him there?
Yeah.
Got It.
So yeah,
he's had the same attitude that you hear from Tommy Norris.
Yeah.
Hey,
can I stay in?
Can I be there,
be with the guys?
Uh,
how much longer were you in Vietnam after that operation?
Dober 31st and I came home,
uh,
on a break in November and then I came home for good January.
So then,
then everybody left in March of 73.
And uh,
woody and the rest of the guys I stayed there and they came back a little funnel
butt Brooksy and woody and Chamberlain and Harry Kinda cool.
And,
and all those guys brought Bill Bradford and stuff.
So,
uh,
and uh,
that was the last sales of course.
Then we got involved with the delta per tune.
You know,
what the Cambodia issue and all that kind of stuff and the Philippines and stuff
like that.
You,
uh,
you talk about coming home here.
I'm going to the book.
Coming back to the team.
This time was different from my first Vietnam tour.
When you were labeled a one tour wonder,
which is by the way still what you get called in this day and age you come home
from your first deployment or even from my Thailand tour at seal team one you
are not a made man until after your second combat rotation.
It was not so much respect from the team veterans as many of them had been on
four or five combat rotations.
It had more to do with acceptance.
I was now one of them when guys like Gary Gallagher and Walt Gustavo and doc
sale came up to you and said,
nice job over there or good work getting your lieutenant back off that beach.
It really meant something.
There was also getting to know my kid who thought I was some stranger,
which I was and getting reacquainted with my wife.
I'd been gone more than I was at home since we were married and there was the
absence of combat.
Both the worrying of having to go in the field and in some ways missing the
anticipation of getting ready to go on an operation and the rush that comes from
combat.
Okay.
I looked at all of this as normal for any seal coming home,
but it was still an adjustment.
So you guys,
same stuff the guys go through now,
no court.
Correct.
Same exact stuff guys go through now.
And our spouses don't get enough credit for what they do.
I mean,
they raise our kids and families,
they take on,
you know,
stuff that we should be there to try to help them with.
But you know,
we have amazing spouses,
uh,
you know,
in the teams too.
And we have a lot better.
You know,
the first thing I mentioned,
my wife,
he said,
where was she?
Did the navy issue or
now we have a whole different outlook.
Thank God.
Uh,
you know,
there are a part of our lives and they should make it better for all of us.
The military wa all the military wives.
Oh yeah.
The generic on what they do.
Yeah.
They're raising the kids,
but they're also fixing water heaters and you know,
repair and plumbing and they're just doing everything in the house.
Like you said,
the stuff that we're supposed to be doing,
if we're home,
we're home.
So they had to put up with all the bs was a man taking a car and they're trying
to,
hell,
I know how to change oil.
They say,
don't try to pull that one over my eyes.
Now going back to the book,
this is you talking and I was notified in September that I would receive the
medal of honor.
A lot goes through your mind when something like that is going to happen to you.
You try and play it down in your mind like it's no big deal,
but it really is a big deal.
Everyone in uniform knows it's a big deal.
I felt humbled and undeserving and I swore that I was not going to change me.
Well,
you know,
Mike Thorne has always been a renegade and probably always will be a renegade.
And then I wasn't going to let it change me.
And,
uh,
so,
you know,
when I went back to get the metal,
they wouldn't let Tommy out of the hospitals,
so I kidnapped,
kept him.
So Tommy was still recovering from the head of news is still going,
this is,
this is what,
a year later,
a year later.
And Tommy still,
I mean,
he's just going through all these,
all the surgeries and everything else.
I mean,
Tommy,
you went through surgeries for six and a half years and are still goes even now.
So,
uh,
you know,
it's unbelievable.
I mean,
so,
but they wouldn't let them out of the hospital go to your ceremony.
So I said,
hey,
this is not,
I said,
I'll bring him back,
you know,
and they said,
no.
I said,
well,
I'm going to get in trouble when I'd take your mouth.
So I kept him for four days.
But in my hotel nerf,
it was name and uh,
everybody in the world's looking forward and the surgeon general of the navy,
which was a three store put me on report and uh,
I had to go to the admirals master does a,
my first one,
you know,
uh,
Tony Fratty who is the Charlie platoon chief.
We used to,
we used to talk about Mike Thornton and we'd say,
you know,
just on random days we'd say,
Hey,
you know what Mike Gordon's doing today,
whatever Mike Fort and wants to do today.
So you just smuggled them out of the hospital against orders,
went to,
went to admirals,
mass.
Uh,
you talk a little bit about the ceremony here.
Going back to the book,
we showed up at the White House for the ceremony.
Then we were all taken in the Oval Office and I was presented with the metal.
I'll never forget President Nixon saying,
Mike,
what can I do for you?
And I said,
well,
Mr President,
you could break
this metal in half and give the other half to this young man,
which was Tom Norris.
You were pointing to standing behind me because he saved my life too.
So again,
even even in the end,
there you are,
uh,
you're looking out for your teammate,
right.
All the way through.
Um,
well,
we still look out for each other even today,
after 46 years.
So I never,
it's a job that you never give up.
Well,
the book,
like I said,
I mean we've covered a traction of the book and it gives so much more detail.
It goes on to talk about the rest of your navy career.
It goes on to talk about,
and obviously it talks about Tommy Norris,
his career as the FBI.
The FBI agent,
by the way,
went into the FBI and wasn't undercover operative.
I mean,
just unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
Okay.
You got to get this book so that you can get the full details of what I'm
talking about.
And you know,
the last thing I wanted to read from the book is,
um,
the citation from your metal of honor.
Please don't.
Yeah,
they can go online and read it.
But the book's called Byod or file,
ladies and
gentleman.
And I tell Ya,
uh,
I,
I never felt I deserved them.
That'll never feel I would deserve the modal.
But you know that I wear that with the honor of the men and women who served
before me,
serve with me and the server after me.
But a lot of people don't know.
We've lost 2 million,
850,
3000 people in this great nation does and Georgia freedoms today.
And that's who we can never forget.
And freedom is not free.
And,
uh,
we must honor each and every one of them and they all deserve the muddle in the
skew,
in their lives for this great nation.
Of course,
Mikey months,
or like I said before,
what a great young man.
I knew Mikey and uh,
uh,
I feel for all our gold star families and uh,
cause I've never,
knock on wood,
I've never lost a child,
but I've lost a lot of,
lot of close,
great friends and uh,
I know what,
what part of they're going through.
But you know,
until you lose a child of your own that you,
God's blessed you to give.
Uh,
it's hard to people to understand that freedom is not free.
This written in blood as you know jack
well.
Yup.
And you know,
I can't even fathom what it's like to lose a child.
I know.
Uh,
you know,
it's,
um,
I can't,
I can't even fathom.
And you know,
when I hear people,
uh,
throwing the word here all around,
you know,
I always,
okay.
I always say
what I hear a lot of veterans say and that is the real heroes didn't come home.
Okay.
Well I agree with you,
but loose,
we did get them all and we still continue to try to get the ones that remains a
little ones home.
Um,
well,
you know,
the,
uh,
like I said,
if you go and get this book,
you can,
you can read it.
You can learn a lot about the,
these operations.
You can learn a lot about people.
Okay.
And what people are capable of.
Yeah.
And what real sacrifice looks like.
And do you know Mike,
Again,
like everyone's going to want to tell you and it tells you all the time,
thank you for the service that you made for our country.
But as a seal,
I want to say thank you for setting the example
that we followed and as a person and as a human being.
Yeah,
thank you for showing us
that we're all capable of more than we thought.
Okay.
And no matter how dire the circumstances,
no matter how many enemy forces are advancing,
no matter how many rounds they're firing at,
you know how many grenades they throw at you,
no matter how big the problems that you face in life,
never quit on yourself.
It never quit on each other.
Very well put or Drucker.
Okay,
sir.
I,
I think we've kept you here long enough.
Well,
Echo,
I'm sure you didn't get a whole lot of speaking time there,
buddy.
No,
enjoying the listener.
That's what eco does.
He get the lucky job to sit back and listen to awesome stories.
But um,
thanks for coming on was my honor.
Thank you for what you're doing and getting the word out to the public,
uh,
book calls.
It was like I say,
freedom is not free,
ladies and gentlemen,
freedoms written in blood and please don't take advantage of this,
you know,
give back to the ones that were given much.
And I goes back to what you and I were talking about too.
I mean the,
the wives,
the children,
the sacrifices they make for their,
for their spouses to go overseas and keep this nation free.
And what's the organization that you have now is called the Michael [inaudible]
Thornton foundations summit.
Fun.
Uh,
we give out money,
uh,
and I don't give out,
you know,
50,000 or a hundred thousand.
I give out a 10,000 here,
5,000 there and,
and our are met foundation and basically,
or I'll give out 20,000,
you know,
and uh,
just a couple of examples.
One was a young marine came back,
he was a corporal.
They retired him.
Uh,
but of course it down,
it takes them anywhere from 19 months to two years to get into the Va.
He had these bad headaches,
but he'd have enough money to pay for.
Hers is copayment.
So I write a check to the MRI to the hospital.
I wrote,
write the check,
they do an MRI fund,
found out he had a brain aneurism and was able to say the young man's life.
The other one,
uh,
we had a guy in special ops.
Uh,
he was an air force major until all Sir Jay sock and he was overseas.
His wife got diagnosed with a stage four cancer.
We put her into Duke University.
I would try to save her life.
Uh,
a friend of mine,
he goes back to the day when we started seal team six and uh,
along which started Jay sock in 1980.
He was our chaplain.
He was a Catholic chaplain and he calls me and said,
Micah here you had a great foundation.
I have a problem.
While I said,
what is your problem?
I do due diligence.
We were able to get their kids into this.
Bakhtin is a Christian school,
which all the kids there range from the age of seven to a 10 or 11.
I can't remember.
And,
uh,
there's three of them,
but they had spent their whole school time there.
Uh,
but the father causes a cold payments,
which they had already built up to a like a hundred something thousand blogs
with the cold payments.
I paid for the kids to wish and wrote a check,
which was a little bit over $18,000,
you know,
for all and put them back in there.
But at least they had a stable platform and everybody knew what was going on
with the mother.
The all the teachers knew the kids and stuff like that.
And then at that period of time,
I go back and I make some phone calls to some good friends of mine in New York
City and they took care of the over the a hundred and something thousand dollars
copayments.
So I put a bandaid on the problem and then I try to go other,
but I mean,
call for fire somewhere.
Yeah.
Farsi.
But I mean,
I were with the,
uh,
the navy seal foundation,
Navy Seal Family Foundation,
the,
uh,
we work with the,
to keep in our history of the museum.
Uh,
uh,
was John Lee does a great job that we do up at Pebble Beach,
the Marine Corps Law Enforcement Foundation,
which is the number one foundation,
um,
uh,
in the nation to give 99 cents of every dollar raised and I give 97 cents of
every dollar raised.
Uh,
I do have one administrator I I pay for,
so my wife and I can travel around and take care of that.
But uh,
uh,
but there's some great foundations out there.
I just told him,
make sure you do your due diligence on their foundations.
You just go online and check them out in there for four star,
five star and find out.
But all the foundation is I work with has got to give at least 94 cents of every
dollar race out to Alpha the calls.
Where can they find your foundation?
Just bullet the mat fund.
Okay.
Uh,
online as fond.
the,
the Mad Yvonne or the Michael,
he Thornton.
I'll put my name on it.
The buck stops with me.
If somebody is pointing fingers,
they only got one finger to point.
I'll take full responsibility.
What I do.
So he's always have,
you know,
don't do,
uh,
and I have people like Bob Kerrey Congress from medal of honor.
It's on my board.
I have an admiral on my board.
I have a two really great businessmen on my board and,
uh,
I have supports of people all in the United States,
which helped support their,
cause they said they used to give money to other foundations,
but I didn't like to with the money was being supported.
So they give me the,
and I,
and uh,
like I say,
we make sure we take care.
I mean,
if like somebody blows up the engine,
the engine having a bad month,
they got laid off and we paid for their rent,
but we write the check to the,
we don't give it to the person,
we give it to the complex or we give it to the hospital or we give it to the
doctor.
So that way I know the money's going where it's supposed to be going so they can
get the take care of their problems.
Well,
obviously,
uh,
your service isn't quite over yet.
You're still serving and still helping veterans and seals across the board.
And once again,
sir,
thank you for coming on.
It's been an honor knowing you,
it's been an honor talking to you and I look forward to talking to you again.
Some total.
We Will Jocko just keep doing what you're doing and our coke keep them out of
trouble.
Yes sir.
Thank you very much for having me on.
Thank you.
All right.
We just took a technical break and Mike Thornton has left the building and went
to go do what Mike Thornton does,
whatever you want,
which is pretty much what every once and it was awesome.
Obviously having them on agree and when Mike Thornton tells you,
don't read my citation and you know,
read the citation.
Simple as that.
No factor.
Yes,
no factor at all,
but awesome having him on obviously.
And now
we want to keep having people like Mike Authority on the podcast.
Yes.
If somebody wanted to help us have people on this podcast,
sure.
Do you have suggestions on how
they could maybe lend to that effort?
Echo Charles the support?
Sure.
Oh yeah.
Like,
basically that's what I'm saying.
A way to support you.
Yeah,
of course.
Here's the way and support yourself kind of thing.
You know what's good for the goose is good.
You know what I'm saying?
Maybe origin were in league with origin as you put it.
Yes,
I do.
Put it that way.
Sure.
Yeah.
So origin Maine.
So origin may mean the state.
Just so to be clear,
yes.
Origin Mei,
any,
oh,
you mean it will like you might be like maybe the state,
the main one kind of Kinda,
which makes sense by the way,
cause he couldn't it be the main one.
Totally.
And so,
you know,
a lot of times like okay,
we'll take the keys.
That's how I first heard of origin.
By the way,
the geese,
like all these keys are dope checked it,
you know,
and of course,
but that technically is kind of a matter of opinion as far as like,
okay,
I'm going to look at this game.
And I'd be like,
okay,
no,
I'm gonna look forward more than Chevy,
whatever,
or the look.
Especially with the geese,
you know,
the,
the subtle differences kind of,
you know,
it's to each their own kind of thing.
Yeah.
I guess you're going into like full on fashion realm here.
I don't go into potentially,
yeah,
I'm looking for functionality.
You probably could've guessed that.
Yes.
So yeah,
and you look into it.
So the functionality part,
yes,
all that of course.
But when you see made in America,
this is like the epitome.
This is the deal that basically the defining
situation.
So you know,
you know how they'll be like,
hey,
made in America,
but then you know,
it's closer or whatever was in this case closed.
But then you say,
oh,
okay,
Dang,
those are good shirts.
You know,
where do you get your blanks from her,
whatever.
Now all we get them from somewhere other than America kind of thing.
No,
the cotton get the cotton from America.
That's what origin did that actual cotton.
Well,
we need you to talk about functionality,
just kind of Fyi.
Uh,
when you have a guy that's making the geese and therefore it's going to weave
the material to make the gies with,
he's going to make material that is specifically the best to have four G,
right.
That's a situation where the origin,
that type of commitment.
Yes.
That's why we're a league with origin.
Yeah,
totally makes sense.
We're kind of,
we have that mindset over on this side.
It makes sense.
Well so yeah,
origin.
That's the one I'm looking forward to my geek
and I'm down for Geeks by the way.
But um,
yeah,
so I'm looking forward to that one.
Origin,
Maine,
Just to be clear just in case it's not just these.
Yeah,
you can get the hash guards dash glad.
Yeah.
And we're going to be making everything there.
We're going to be making everything there.
I everything that I utilize in my life.
Yeah.
I'm going to make,
it's like you.
So you're going to kind of come out with almost like a life kit is really what
it is.
It's a code.
Don't use the Reebok terminology bro.
Cause the Reebok calls it like the UFC fight kit.
Ah,
okay.
But I didn't know that man.
Not Not the word kit is a university of where your kid is a universal word,
which I do concur with.
Right.
But what did you call it,
the kid?
That's what I called it,
I guess so.
So you could call it the Brits call it kit.
They call their op gear.
Like their web gear?
Yeah,
they call it kit.
Which means that we also,
because we have interoperability with the Brits and the Aussies.
Sure.
So we also tend to call our gear kit.
So yes.
In fact you are correct.
If you were to say,
I'm going to make all my kit there,
the answer is yes.
But
there's a fine line where people might think of the UFC fight kit,
which didn't go over real well when they first came out.
Hey,
and you know we're going to let that be their thing for sure.
As far as he's going well or not going well,
this one,
what would it be?
Kind of like the dis,
the unofficial discipline equals freedom kit.
How about we just call it gear?
Yeah.
Or we could just call it gear.
I guess that's my vote.
I don't rule the world.
So if you want to call it a kid on your side and I'll call it a gear over here.
Let's do that.
You know that way you're comfortable.
I'm a him all about everyone being comfortable with what they're saying.
Technically it will be a kit with gear in it and okay.
This traditional,
that's a traditional use of the word kit,
right?
Right.
That's what,
okay.
Oh,
You got like five kids.
I got a survival kit when I was six years old and it's got a compass and a
whistle and a pair of matches in it.
What happens if you use both matches?
You're in trouble.
So that's a survival kit.
Why do you have a a whistle?
You just said whistle cause you know when you're a little kid you get lost in
the weeds.
Would you supposed to blow on the whistle for awhile until they find,
you know,
sorry,
that doesn't happen in Kona.
Not that I know.
What'd you do in collide?
When you got lost,
you just keep heading in one direction and you're you to the ocean or up in the
mountains.
So it's kind of,
they call it Malka Malka is mountain and MCI is ocean.
So that's kind of the directions.
Otherwise you just keep walking.
That's a good lesson for life to go into the mountains.
One time.
Long story,
maybe some other time.
Back to origin please.
Another dive.
So boom,
origin,
Maine,
all made in America.
Rash guards,
Jeez.
All that stuffs.
This is like,
yeah.
And by the way,
supplements there too.
Yeah.
Supplements and labs.
So you can find it all there.
And,
and we're going to make basically what we're talking about here,
Jocko supplements,
because again,
know what do I specifically want?
I'm pretty particular.
Let's make that thing.
Yeah.
And then we go forward.
The good part about that is to,
as you're kind of one of these guys,
you can rest assured you're not going to have like this,
these weird extra things like on an oaf hair dye or something like that.
They will not be selling hair dye.
Yeah,
yeah.
Or something like this.
So yeah,
that'd be good.
The good stuff for sure.
Or do you mean.com also
support yourself?
So on it.
I'm not going to go into my kettle bells situation again this time.
Actually yesterday I worked at,
I didn't do kettle bells.
I did.
I did you that was,
it was like an article that said that those little goblet squats upwards but
not,
yeah,
that was a funny article for sure.
Laughed.
You know what the title was called?
Something along the lines of,
I'm trying to make remembering exact,
it's,
it was called 14 ways to avoid being bigger to remain a puny little weakling.
Actually puny I think.
No,
do we,
do we be within there?
So apparently given number whatever number that was,
I'm going to remain a puny little dweeb apparently.
Here's the thing,
are those really goblet squats though?
Cause Goblet Squat?
No,
I know it should do you do that?
You basically do a front squat double rack,
double rack yet cause Goblin is like,
cause this is the form,
the shape of album that here and that's how you hold it.
Yeah.
It is kind of,
well what if you use like a huge ass kettle bell?
I'm a metcon.
Yeah,
that could work.
In fact,
I mean respect to the author that,
I forget who wrote it or whatever,
but it was a real subjective really.
You know,
I think it was more of like a shock article.
Kind of just feels the laugh.
But if you take that serious directive out there trying to help people that have
skinny knees
proud of though,
is he real proud of that?
I looking look at you anyway.
I didn't really like the article on that level,
but for a laugh it was good.
And and factually,
here's the deal.
We're kettlebells are alleged yet.
Yeah.
And they are cross religion.
But here's the thing,
there was a good point.
Hey,
yeah.
I'll tell you what.
You know what you're talking about,
what you,
what you used to,
you're good at what you're used to.
Yeah.
For some reason I hurt my wrist or something.
Or I heard something and I couldn't do back squats or front squats.
I was,
yeah it was,
maybe there's more,
maybe it was my shoulder.
Anyways,
I was doing goblet squats with the,
uh,
with my big kettle bell,
which is 40 kilograms and I,
I had put on the schedule of what I was going to do like 25 it was a bunch of,
it was a metcon scenarios,
but the first number was 25.
There was 25,
2015.
Oh the reps.
Yeah.
Those are the rest 25 hurt.
Yeah I was Dang cause it's only,
it's only 88 pounds.
Right.
That should be in,
that should be pretty insignificant.
But you really do when you do those goblet squats.
Yeah.
You're using your whole body to keep that thing alive.
It's good.
Olympic my,
yeah,
I think I'm used to it now.
I think that,
yeah.
And I got used to it and it's pretty short period of time that that's what was
cool.
Yeah.
So on at.com you can get that kind of stuff there if you want the cool ones.
I think I and I don't know,
cause then you know I didn't,
haven't ventured out and I don't think I ever will venture out to go see where I
can get other kettle bells from.
No need really.
Cause you can buy the regular ones or the adult ones and let's face it man,
you take enough pictures of the dolt ones for your Instagram,
wherever you take pictures for and you kind of can't go back.
You can't.
Mm.
So keep that in mind yourself into a kettle bell.
Exactly.
Right.
Anyway,
you and your social media,
yeah.
Have painted yourself into this yes.
Corner,
which is not a bad thing necessarily on a.com/jocko.
That's where you get these things.
Painting myself into a corner with my social media.
I'm going to wake up everyday at four 30.
Yeah,
you've got to post it.
Guess what?
The other day I got home at three o'clock in the morning or I got,
I didn't get to sleep until like one 30 and when I woke up in the morning I was
really tired.
Yeah.
And uh,
okay.
I was,
gee,
what am I going to do?
I'm,
I'm painting in the corner.
I had to say,
hey guys,
I'm,
I'm going back to sleep.
And I actually went back to sleep.
I told everyone,
Dan.
See that's good though.
You took accountability though.
Light.
That's just lying.
Which I don't support.
Oh,
if you didn't do that,
if I said,
Oh,
if I woke up,
took a picture of my watch,
which I've had people say like,
Oh,
I bet you just wake up.
Or did you ever sometimes just wake up in the morning,
take a picture,
you're watching to go back to sleep?
No,
actually I don't do that.
Yeah.
It doesn't seem like you could ever bring yourself to do that.
We'll look why would even want it,
you know?
We didn't want to do that.
It's a horrible scenario.
It kind of defeats the purpose,
right?
Yeah.
The whole purpose.
So the other day woke up,
took a picture of my watch,
and I was like,
I got to go back to bed.
I'm too freaking tired.
So in fact her bed,
but you didn't post it note?
No,
I'm going back to bed.
I'm sorry.
Hold the line for me.
Yeah,
I think you're on the cover for me actually,
that one time we got home cover and snooze.
You guys covering it after that would be over here.
Snoozing.
Well,
hey,
that's the freedom part though.
Well,
we always say discipline.
You have the freedom to,
hey man,
you got us sometimes,
but you can't like,
um,
well,
especially if you're working out and you don't,
you straight up don't get enough sleep.
I'm not saying you don't.
You don't,
right.
That's not what I'm saying right now.
But if you,
the proverbial you,
us,
when we don't get enough recovery.
Uh Huh.
Okay.
Which sleep is recovery,
but that's not a good thing,
man.
So every once in a while you got to exercise that restraint
in the form of the freedom to sleep in.
Yeah.
Well I did.
Amen.
That's part of life.
Anyway,
on it also the whole painting yourself in the corner of gate.
So I got this jump rope and it's like,
you know that I know how up to date you are on the new general technology
getting better.
They're,
yeah,
they're dope.
And here's the thing.
If you just buy a regular jump rope,
like you'll see the difference.
And I mentioned that because I got an a on it jump rope.
I told you about the time my neighbor taught me how to do the crossover,
and that's what it really hit me like.
This is the dope jump rope.
So if you want to upgrade your jump rope,
boom on it,
that's the one in fact,
just go on there.
See what,
what up.
See what they have.
A lot of good stuff,
a lot of good stuff.
Also,
good way to support when we get this book by honor bound
Tom Norris,
Mike Thorton and Dick Couch.
When you get this book going to our website,
[inaudible] dot com there's a book section top menu.
Boom.
Click on their books from podcasts by episode.
By the way,
this is episode 89 click through there.
It'll take you to Amazon and you get your books there,
or you're,
if you can do some other shopping,
if you're gonna buy a lawnmower,
duct tape,
whatever,
click through there.
Good way to support,
you know,
small little actions.
Just one little click through.
Big reaction by way of support.
Also,
subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already.
Itunes,
stitcher,
Google,
play all these podcasting,
providing platforms and youtube for the video version of this podcast and
excerpts and some other various little video things.
That's a good way to support.
Also,
Jack was a store.
It's called Jocko store chocolate store.com.
There are hats.
They're good hats.
Trucker hats,
flex fit three colors.
Wait,
flex fit their flex him.
they don't have the little thing in the back were snapped back,
snapped back.
No,
I think their flex fit and they don't make trucker hats that are flex it.
I don't think they do now.
Oh,
okay.
Pretty sure I'm fairly positive there.
Their hats and their,
their dope.
Yeah.
I thought you were gonna bring me nine of them.
Yeah,
I didn't do that.
That was,
that's a bummer.
Jocko has a store,
but TACO has no hats.
There is,
Oh,
you know what?
There's this other kind of hat.
I think it's called like,
like an operator hat.
It's like real simple.
Anyway,
I'm thinking about doing that one too.
Interesting.
In the event of you not being as into the trucker hat is maybe something else
will see flex it as well.
That's my thing is flex fit.
Cool.
Is that good?
Yeah.
Flux.
It has purpose.
I just have never seen a trucker's hat flex fit.
Yeah.
And I doubt I'm going to see one now.
No Man,
it's the new stuff apparently.
But yeah,
some of the stuff on there.
There's some shorts on there.
Cool stuff.
Jock Leven has a shirt that he designed,
which is cool layers if you will.
Um,
just,
I like the way you promote the shirt that has your picture on it.
You proud of that aren't,
you know I'm not actually because I didn't want that one.
No,
I didn't want,
I didn't want my picture on there actually.
That's true.
I gotta give you that Echo.
Did Not want to have an echo shirt cause it does to me.
Demanded it vetoed it.
[inaudible] called Jocko store.
I got some pull.
Yeah.
Italians dark.
And I'm not saying to buy this shirt.
I'm not saying nobody a hat.
I'm thinking,
go on the store,
drugstore.com again,
if he liked something,
get something good support.
Also
psychological warfare,
if he didn't know what that is.
It's an album with tracks,
Jocko tracks.
And these tracks help you get through moments of weakness in your campaign
against weakness.
Every once in a while when you wage these hard campaigns against weakness,
against your,
you know,
waking up early,
sticking to the Diet,
workout,
all this stuff.
Sometimes you get moments of fatigue,
sometimes even the strongest have their moments of fatigue.
That's affirmative.
So this psychological warfare,
these tracks,
they're like little spots for those moments of fatigue.
Get you through it,
no problem.
Psychologically,
then you act boom.
So yeah,
that's a good one.
So if you're,
you know,
waking up early,
like I said,
you're waking up early,
you feel like even the snooze,
listen to psychological warfare,
one of those tracks on there,
I think it's called get up and get after it.
You will not hit the snooze.
Good one.
Yup.
That's it.
It's like electrical repaired.
Jocko Willink anywhere,
iTunes,
uh,
where else?
Amazon music,
all these places where he,
where they sell mp3s.
You can get him there.
Yup.
Uh,
yeah.
This book that,
that we covered today by Mike Bordin,
by Tommy Norris and by Dick Couch,
you can get,
you got to get this book.
It's a great book.
It's a great read and that's a good place to start.
So much more detailed than I went over today where we just as I was walking out,
Mike and his wife and I was telling her that,
I was explaining to him that it's like the debrief I wanted since I was an e
four in the navy to wanting to know what happened and wanted the details.
Well now we got them and there was some crazy details.
By the way.
He's crazy.
He's,
he's,
he's talking about how,
yeah.
You know,
my friend gets his forehead blown off or whatever.
You can see his brain,
all this stuff,
even in a movie that,
that'd be pretty graphic scene.
Even a movie that'd be unbelievable.
Lucky back,
all of that movie wasn't really realistic because the guy had his head blown off
and then he lived.
But that was a crazy part though,
right on that movie.
Yeah.
You know,
but yeah.
Well it really happened.
Oh.
So He's,
you know,
he has him,
his other guy,
he shot by the way,
and he's like,
and he's going,
you know,
through the ocean,
all this stuff and shrapnel in his back from the made that he threw back five
times.
Yeah.
It's so crazy.
And then we're sitting here and he safe.
He's sitting right there.
That's the guy who really did that.
You know,
he's not,
I mean,
respect.
Of course acting is cool and dope furrow,
but that's not an actor.
That's the guy who really did it heavy.
But that's heavy.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Um,
so get the book,
read about it,
read the rest of details that
we barely even scratched the surface on.
Uh,
also some other books you can get,
you can get a book called extreme ownership.
It's about leadership.
Yeah.
Okay.
It teaches you how to lead.
Sure.
It's a book that I wish I had when I was a young leader,
but I didn't have it.
I wasn't old enough to have written it and giving it back to myself yet.
Yeah.
It doesn't work like that.
Also,
we're speaking of being young.
You need another book called the way of the warrior kid,
which is awesome because kids all over the place,
like parents now when I'm speaking somewhere,
they bring their kids.
Yeah.
So I get to meet these kids,
kids that are getting graft riff,
which is pretty awesome.
So where the warrior kid
as so many kids are like doing pull ups now.
Yeah.
So I'll just going to get some real thing.
My daughter will be like bothering me debt that I want to do.
Pull ups.
[inaudible] she didn't want to go.
You don't get that from reading Cinderella.
Cinderella did not make her want to want to do that.
Right,
right.
I did tell her the story of Cinderella last night.
Coincidentally.
She really wouldn't want to do any pull ups about it though.
No,
I didn't compel her to go do any compel her to eat better.
No.
Did it compel her to study hard?
No,
she just said it was beautiful.
Okay.
So compelled some thoughts of beauty but it didn't compel any change of
direction and that I know no action taken.
I'm going with the way of the warrior King Bay.
Me Too.
Uh,
also discipline equals freedom.
Freedom field manual is coming out that could compel you to get after it.
Yeah,
it could.
I check it out.
There's no books like it
and it's like it's a manual.
You know how like when you listen you're like,
okay,
I can,
you know,
you kind of get a feel,
but I know there's nothing,
there's nothing vague about the manual.
It tells you what to do.
Yeah.
And it also talks about some thoughts that are in my head.
So it is interesting.
You can get it.
I appreciate it.
Also origin Maine,
you already covered that,
which is good.
That is now us by the way.
We're partnered.
So when you start your Jujitsu journey or if you're on your Jujitsu journey,
check it out.
Come and get it.
If you're on the path of getting after it.
Yeah.
Do it with us at origin and also if you want to partner with us from a
leadership perspective in your business.
Our business,
Asheville on front leadership consulting,
that's what we do.
Me,
Leif,
Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
info@echelonfront.com don't Google and look for Jocko speaking cause that's
going to give you a speaker's agent that's going to charge you more money.
Is there something going to be like a bureau or speakers bureau,
a speaker's agent,
what they do and,
and they're trying to provide a service they're trying to get,
they're trying to connect speakers with people that need speakers,
but we don't need anyone to connect us with people that need speakers.
You can go straight to echelon front.com right.
So that's that.
Also
the monster,
September 14th and 15th in San Diego.
Just to clarify,
the first three monsters were based on the same material because we did it on
the west,
on the east,
and then in the center of the country.
Just to clarify,
now that now this muster muster for is a new material,
so it's different.
New approaches.
New Stories is not sold out yet,
but it will be.
So if you want to come register now,
extreme ownership.com
and while you're waiting for the monster,
if you have a question
for us,
you can ask that question on the interwebs were there?
Yeah,
on the Twitter,
the Instagram and dad's face,
he ball echo is an echo.
Charles and I m at Jocko Willink also snapchat.
Are you on there?
I am on there and I posted Ah,
snap so far.
One snap and it disappears after 24 hours.
Yeah.
So you can't go,
I'm good.
I'm still working to figure out like how I'm supposed to utilize this thing.
Yeah.
So we'll continue working on that one.
And that's it.
That's how you can get in touch with us.
And uh,
finally
tell anybody else sits out there who thinks maybe you're being overwhelmed or
you think the deck is stacked against you or you think you can't go on anymore.
Yeah.
Think about Mike Thornton
and remember that you are capable of so much more
as long as you never give up and keep getting after it.
Hm.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.